everybody hello hello welcome to dokeyverse 30k apex creator
tournament cobbled together in less than a week i'm so tired
oh we made it we made a tournament within less than a week
i'm like oh my god you don't understand i yesterday I woke
up at 12 p.m.
Did my, did my dailies, walked dad, fed dad.
Oh my god, everything's a blur right now.
Worked on this tournament all the way till 5 in the morning.
I went to bed at 5 in the morning yesterday.
Woke up at 9 a.m.
backed away.
Oh my, anything that could go wrong has gone, but it's a
miracle.
I did it though.
It's the hardest part of this entire tournament is over.
Like we just play the game now.
Oh my god.
I'm, I'm just, everybody's finally confirmed.
Like you cannot imagine how many people reached out I pulled
you're like why isn't Doki posting like any details about
you don't understand the last player because people were
either dropping out obligations something came out some
event every type of event was going on either this weekend
or today everything what I now realized why the other I it
was I felt oh my god when I said yes I was like it's it'll
be fine I can like it'll be fine like getting 10 i just need
to get 10 teams that's all i need to do i thank god it was
only 10 teams i don't know how i i don't think i don't even
know there will be a tournament if i had to grab 20 people
20 teams i little did i know i'm oh but i made it i did it i
was like It's just 30 people.
I can find 30.
You don't.
The amount of people I've DMed, I've asked, I've reached out
to, pulled out from my connections.
Some people were like, Toki, oh man, if I did have this, I
would have said yes.
Oh, just invite, please invite me to the next turn.
Maybe do something similar again.
I would love to do it.
I was like, but I need you now.
I need you now.
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I, I, I, I need you now.
I cashed in so many favors.
I'm really like, I'll owe you.
I thank you so much.
The last player.
Okay, there was a team that had three rotating players in
and out.
They were like, okay.
The first one was like, I thought we were good to go.
everything set up yesterday last night it was 11 p.m.
I got a message oh I'm a minor I didn't realize the service
were 18 plus and I'm like you're you're you're underage why
did oh my god I thought every time I found a replacement I
found a player and I was ready to go.
And I was like, let's go.
We did it.
We've confirmed everything.
Something will come up.
I kept being like, I just need to find two more people.
I just need to find something came up.
I just need to find two more people.
And then I need to find, and then something came up.
And then, and then, all right.
So I was like, that's cool.
Cool.
This is going to be hard because I had to find, I need to
find someone at 11 p.m.
and then I got another person and he was like I have to flip
my schedule for this but But I think I could do it and I was
like OK that's fine and I went to bed because it was 5 in
the morning and I woke up got a message from him and he was
like Hey I'm going to go to bed I'm going to go to bed I'm
going to go to bed and I'm going to but I got someone else
to replace me.
And then I was like, okay, cool.
What's this discord?
And then he was already gone.
He was already, he was already, did not reply.
I was like, oh, no.
What do you, I, how do I connect to him?
Luckily, luckily, um, he already joined the discord.
But I didn't realize that.
And I was like, oh, thank, yeah, but he was not, because I,
I, by the way, I personally reached out to involved in this
tournament and I've given like talked to each and one of
them just to like all the details I talked to every single
one of them like this all personally reached out by me some
teams I cobbled together like your friends out
congratulations I was just like your friends you got I hope
you guys I actually thought about it too um I was like uh
well Beto's team there is like he made his own team i was
like do you want me to cobble assign you teammates or are
you good with some of them i cobbled together some of them
chose to uh play with friends but a lot majority of them i
fucking fucking mushed together and was like congratulations
crossover time so this tournament is a crossover between
fighting the fgc community and the uh fps community um so
it's not just from apex there's like players from different
types of fps games as well and there's a lot of players
you've seen in other fighting games like such as say jam
slam or the new challengers or like street fighter Tekken
you see a lot of these players that i wanted to make
something special where um because it is a street fighter 6
collab with apex legends and so i made it i invite a lot of
the fgc people um uh in the tournament as well and i and
there are some apex there's like two apex pros and some apex
content creators but i've told the apex content creators and
the apex pros to please be nice I was like, please, like
personally talk to every one of them.
And I was like, please be nice.
Yes, I will have all the graph.
I will show you guys the graphics.
I was like, please be gentle.
Please be nice.
If you think you're doing too much, please calm down.
But oh my God, when I wrote that I was like, I wrote down my
trauma on my server.
All right.
So yeah, I shot messages to everyone.
There's just so many events.
There were conventions.
I asked some people.
They're like, there's a riff-bind event going on that day.
I was like, okay, it's fine.
And then others were like, I actually start my vacation
tomorrow.
I've been like, it's all right.
And there's like streamer events being like, yeah, there's a
Twitch rivals today.
Or like, I have to prepare for a fighting game tournament.
Or like, actually, I have to go to work at that time.
And I was just like, oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's alright.
I get it.
There's a Red Bull event.
There's IRL event.
I have to film something for a bit.
You don't understand.
There's rivals.
There's rivals Ignite.
I was like, okay.
It was the busiest Friday ever.
And it was actually for some reason.
And there's Rust Kingdom going on too.
For some reason, this Friday was just every conceivable
event was on this Friday.
It is a miracle.
I managed to pull this off within a week.
I made the rules.
I drafted the rules.
I drafted the game modes.
I recruited the players.
I talked to every single individual.
I made sure everybody is comfortable.
I explained everything.
Went step by step.
Gave everybody apex coins.
Show them how to redeem the coins.
Ask them to make a battle.
Oh my god.
Individual each and every single.
Because I want to make sure everybody's comfortable.
A lot of people are doing this for me.
Being able to give up their time out of their schedules.
Especially so last minute.
of people i've messaged being like they're gonna talk to
each other it's like dokey told me i was the last person she
needs to recruit and someone's like wait a minute dokey told
me i was the last person she needed because so they don't
understand there are so many people i said you're the last
person i need but then it was never the last person i need
there was so many people i wrote that to, they were not, it
was not just them that they were the last person I need.
There was always someone that was the, no, the thing is, at
that time, there was the no, at that time, there was someone
I need, like they were the last, but then something always
happens.
something at that time it's like i swear to you're gonna be
the last last person i need
i even had people i contacted at three in the morning to
come and clutch for me because the thing is i need this
tournament to be like a mix of like big, medium, and small
streamers.
So it's like a comp, like a mix of balance of all of them.
So there was like, I looked at, there was like data and I
was just like looking at it and be like, okay, this person
dropout.
So I need to find someone similar to replace them.
And then someone similar in skill range to replace this
person.
And then this FGC person dropped out.
So I need to find an FGC person to replace the, and then I
was just like numbers everywhere names everywhere I and then
there was the amount of people I find out that live in a
specific place I didn't realize that they live in and then
they'll join and was like oh shit I actually live here so
like I and I was like what I oh my god I had someone that
was like, like they're in America.
They're American.
And I found out that they're like, oh, I'm actually like
right now not in America.
That's just like, right now, like the one time they were not
in America.
They, the one time they were, Not in America at that exact
moment
They were like traveling at that exact moment, but they had
to be physically in that in in those Regions they have to be
physically there to participate and the one time and
oh my there's so many there was so many so a huge shout out
huge thank you to everyone for participating and everyone
coming in clutch i owe all of them a big time and like like
i owed him so much and i really appreciate i cannot believe
magic cobbles us together within a week i did not realize
how hard it was going to be i thought usually like it'd be
usually if it was any other i feel like if it was any other
week any other time it wouldn't have been this hard because
it just happened to be a lot of games were being released a
lot of games were being released today a lot of obligations
were being it was just like i was oh so many people had so
many plans on specifically here i personally gave everybody
that join info, talk to them, explain their rules.
I really want to personally thank everyone for joining.
And yeah, it's welcome to my 30K creator tournament.
Huge shout out and thank you to Apex for I guess this
opportunity.
I pulled it off.
I hope.
I pulled off the hardest part.
It's just all about the execution now.
It's just we had subs lined up dude just by the way what a
fucked up day i spilled my drink this morning too i woke up
found out i need to find one more sub and then i spilled my
drink on the floor i actually knocked my drink on the floor
like and i was just like oh so i ran out of dog food i
forgot to or amazon order it because dad's dog food is like
very specific because he needs to like have like um um
because he has allergies like allergies so like i tend to
give him like a a very specific type of wet food um and so i
had to uber eat um some cans this morning because i forgot
to order he ran literally ran out today but i got the i got
the food and i was a mess guys i was a mess but we did it we
fucking did it everybody i'm we pulled it up huge shout out
to the apex team to battlefly team um we pulled it off all
together like you really got to like set up the rules
official rules the battlefly huge shout out about apex for
looking on this wild ass ride that we were all in for three
days i worked on this turn like yesterday was crazy i thing
i was i was working on this term messaging everybody
messaging everyone i know um gathering talking to everybody
waiting for replies 12 p.m all the way to 5 a.m working on
the tournament yesterday and then day before went to bed at
5 in the morning working on this tournament and then day
before working on a tournament not as that's crazy as before
because i went in like fucking yay like just because i want
i i just care so much i just care too much because i I put a
lot of my own personal hours uh into this and like uh and
like I just wanted this tournament to be um to be as best as
it could be despite how little time I had to put it to
little time I had in general and uh I care a lot I really
did I really cared a lot and I try to pull players from
different communities and different games and also like
because I want to we want to show more uh casual side of
apex it's not just like rank the try hard sweat and all them
you know I want like not the normal game mode I want to say
this tournament it has none of the actual normal game like
the normal games of apex legends we're gonna be focusing
more on the more casual side and more fun side so there are
of new players going in and a lot of street fighter players
going as well because this is the street fighter 6 collab
that is happening with apex legends and so i showcase it to
people who are not usual uh apex viewers itself um and so a
lot uh we want to show it to various other communities uh
and not showing this another side of apex um the more casual
uh fun side of apex and the newest game that they're doing
is actually really really fun i was trying it out the last
two nights and it's it's actually it's basically street
fighting but like in a battle royale sense um and um and i
wanted to like you know showcase the viewers uh like maybe
like showcase viewers to uh come back to check out apex uh
for those who might have not played apex in a while um maybe
Like you get to see the new stuff that's in apex and maybe
want to come back to it check it out yourself And I think
that's like my vision for this tournament And like for the
viewers For viewers and for all the other participants
Simple mind I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you did and you think the other sisters left you out
to drive out to drive shame on Simple thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
It was just not my day or not my not my week guys
like all right participants the moment you've all been
waiting for all right before that we got talk about other
stuff though so not the moment you've all been waiting for
we're we have other moments that you might not have been
waiting for by half the but these are also equally as
important so this is finalized everyone's in the server so
they can't leave now they can't
Everyone's in You can't leave There's no There's no leaving
now
It's over You are forced to play now You've had your chance
to drop out Okay All right, so welcome to the Doki Bird
Creative Tournament.
Like I said, huge shout out to Apex and BioFly for helping
me putting all of this together.
You and dad was like, don't leave.
Hey, no, no, go.
Oh, all right.
So the total prize pool, as I said, is 30 grand.
And this was, the prize pool was provided by apex slash
battlefly um and they asked me to help organize all of this
put all of this together you have no idea how many people i
vented to and like had a not okay maybe break i don't want
to say breakdown but it is pretty accurate every time
someone said yes or they say no if someone said yes or no
and they say yes i would thank you so much i was just like i
i really appreciate you and i thank you for coming in clutch
and then people who said no and out they say no i'd be like
i understand this is very last minute and i honestly you
saying yes would have been a miracle but i shot my shot and
you know i
I was like, I don't blame you.
It's so last minute.
I, but thank you so much for considering.
And I did.
So, oh, yes, Christ, no, Christ.
Yeah.
I, no, I was like, I totally understand.
Like, it was just, I was like, you can, like, even when I
was like, you can say no.
Kamar, or you can say no, the tournament is in three days.
And it wasn't, it wasn't guilt tripping.
No, no, no, no, okay, okay, sound, I swear to God, it was, I
was literally just reassuring them that it's fine, that it
was fine.
Like, I reassured them.
Anyway, anyway, um,
Uh...
Anyway, so...
Each tournament...
Uh...
Sorry, sorry, my manager messaged me something.
I don't understand what you mean by this.
Alright.
So, each game...
Each game has its own prize pool.
But...
no team can farm first place so like if they won first place
again they do not get first place money they will it will
automatically go towards second place so if they already won
first place in the previous games um first play second place
will move up to first place so that cannot be farmed um just
in case you know just so it makes it fair so no one team
just farms three grand every game um so and if second place
already won first place it will go to third place the third
place will win one grand like if that's how the it's gonna
go so each game itself will have a 6k prize pool um after
that but but but uh uh all right so all right what are what
are the game modes So we are going to start off with a
warm-up game, and the warm-up game is the wildcards mode.
So if you guys ever played the wildcard mode, if anyone's
ever played the wildcard mode for Street Fighter, it's
literally just Street Fighter abilities in the wildcard
mode, and we're going to warm up with that for those new
players who might need a bit of warm-up to get used to the
abilities and everything, no money no money in it it's just
there to play we're just playing it just for them to check
out the mode for those who might not have time to check it
out yet um at least everybody has a chance to like warm up
with it and get situated with it and then right after that
is the first event which is boxing ring roy yab so basically
each team has selected a tribute to represent the team like
as if it's like Street Fighter.
So it's going to be a 1v1 single elimination boxing
tournament in Olympus.
And it's going to be best of three per round.
So it's like a set.
You play one set.
So and you can use your melee slash Street Fighter abilities
when you're doing your 1v1.
So if you guys ever played the game mode, it's literally
just Street Fighter.
and so that's basically the first event and there's gonna be
a whole bracket and everything if people will move up the
brackets all the way to the finals so that is the first
event after that will be a melee's and abilities only so you
made trios battle royale on e-district so only melee's and
only abilities so you can use damaging abilities by the way
but guns and grenades are banned but healing is allowed and
these are the legends that are banned so people can't play
them it's fuse mad maggie rampart vantage caustic and
catalyst so all the other characters are you're free to
fucking go wild uh you guys might have noticed we included
some sword some characters that may or may not be that may
or may not be a little bit broken but there is ways to
counter it but i specifically chose these six characters
because there's like it's just it's not as fun during final
ring i chose some characters in final ring but then these
characters i was like we can't have these characters in
final ring we can so um so that is uh that is uh all the
characters that you are not allowed to play uh also i had
someone ask me a question real quick
Which mode exactly?
A lot of them are punching.
All right.
Next slide.
Event 3.
Wildcard match again.
People, players who have reached Masters Plus are only
restricted to melee and street fighter abilities.
So they are not allowed.
allowed to use any guns so event some teams are considered
like the pros they aren't allowed to use any of the guns um
they're only allowed to do is the mailing and tree fighter
abilities we have five a three and five are both that event
four is hide and seek so be me matara and alter we will be
the seekers we don't gain anything we don't gain any extra
prizes and points or anything uh but We will be playing.
We will be hunting down people.
I have the perfect comp for this, by the way.
I I brainstormed the perfect comp for all of this.
So, um, and we are not allowed to play Pathfinder,
Bloodhound, Seer, Valkyrie, or Crypto.
So that will be banned.
Um, that will already be banned.
Um, and, but the, the hideers can play whatever the fuck
they want.
Just go wild.
Uh, so yeah, that is all the game modes.
that's all the game modes that's going in uh in tournament
mode so yeah uh let's see sorry i'm sending in the slide
because they don't know what's been and what's not been uh
sorry i'm fucking multitasking here uh let me uh send the
slide over because they're like what's gonna oh my gosh too
many images in this folder so it takes forever to load
anything all right teams time team the moment you're all
waiting for the moment you've all been waiting for it like I
said each game mode uh it's its own prize pool and
everything so uh so don't worry I have to worry about that
uh all right meet your teams oh my gosh where do I go don't
worry I'll fucking rotate after this all right meet the
teams shout out to everybody thank God recognize a lot of
them from various other games or street fighter or uh techin
or smash they're everywhere all right so my team one and
done it's me matara and alter um huge shout to matara and
alter uh for for joe for agreeing to join my team at one
point when i thought it was done And I was like I forgot to
get players for my own team And by the time I got players
for my own team I had to get players for other teams too So
it was a never-ending cycle guys It was a never-ending cycle
You're the last one I need, please I need you to join
Alright Alright, so team 2, Glorps Is Gully, Hewn, and Sure4
Team 3, 6, 7 is SK, Japanese, Korea, and Flats.
Surprisingly, a lot of people might be surprised by this,
but these were all individually recruited, and I just
blopped them together.
Anyway, oh, wait, that's...
It's high, and it's...
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me...
I sent the wrong slide.
Oh.
all right all right here you go um sorry so yeah i i
actually individually put all of them together so i was like
you three perfect you three you guys all know each other
it's perfect i all individually reached out to all three of
them Anyway, wait, oh my gosh, okay.
Sorry, everybody's reaching out for me for, like, questions
and stuff.
Anyway, two and a half Smash players, Fatal, Cody, and
Riddles.
This was their own, they made this team themselves.
So this was their own made team and everything.
But you guys might recognize them in different fighting
games.
uh teaming for nasu mr raffle waffles and that punch kit
shout out to raffle waffles i asked if he could join like i
was you know i was shooting shots randomly getting all my
connects like everyone i've ever done anything with just
seeing who would say yes and raffle waffles was like i
actually have something to do in the morning so please uh
reach out to me in nine hours and then i can let you know if
i'm be if i can do this or not so i put him i was like all
right i'm gonna put you there just i'm i'm putting it all in
that you are you it's like based that basically he was like
it's 12 30 right now 12 40 right now so i had i i woke up 9
a.m message mr raffle waffles and be like so could you can
you do it and he was like i can do it he's like yeah
everything's good i'll be there.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
Like, I'm all in.
I was just like, I was just like, get back.
He's like, message me in nine hours.
And I was like, I was like, oh, thank God.
I, there was a plan B, but at that point, I was just like,
I, I don't want, I, please, this must, no, I can't have one
last guy.
I, I, I, real, well, Real one.
The Campbell paid up.
Raging Demons is the Dyrus in a praise.
Swag Champions is Heavenly Crusader and Saja.
Perfect is Try Hard JP, Lex, and Zuni.
Shuriken Spammers is Sang, Gumi, and saint sakura and
finally team manta is manta isa and nia huge shout out to
isa because i messaged her at three in the morning i
messaged her at three in the morning today being like do you
think you can do this and then she was in bed and was like
how long would this turn be.
And I was like, it'll be around this.
And she's like, I can do it.
And I was like, oh, thank God, I owe you.
I was like, you are the last person I need.
This at that time, before I went to bed, she was the last
person I had to confirm.
By the way, before I went to bed, she was I had to confirm
until I woke up and I had one more last person to confirm.
I know.
So in the end, she was the second last person I had to
confirm.
Who was the actual last person I had to confirm?
The very, very last person is Zuni.
was the absolute the final real last person i had to confirm
i so these are your teams one last job in the end i really
really hope everyone has fun um and everyone enjoys
themselves because there are there are good players in it
but i have personally to please after the first warm-up
match to determine the skill range of like how hard you can
go so like i have personally requested each individual who i
saw were good players and asked if they could um if they
could like you know uh focus more on the fun aspect of this
tournament and not so i you know like the people i picked
personally i picked a lot of people personally and uh and uh
tried my best to uh you know to just try and make it a fun
environment for everybody and since it is like you know it's
not the actual apex game mode it's the it's the wild card
it's mostly the wild card mode and it's it's it's chaotic
the wild card game mode is very chaotic there's a lot of
response and everything you're gonna see it i'm gonna hop in
to vc now i think matara and Altair might be there already.
But yes, I did it.
Within a week, I've cobbled all of this together.
I don't know how I pulled this off.
It was a miracle.
And you shout out to the Apex team and the Battlefly team
for being along on this fucking crazy-ass ride.
We confirmed all the rules and everything literally last
night.
Like official, like people reviewing and everything.
like with like for like uh just like making sure like
everything is fully confirmed and all that like we had the
rules drafted but it was like you know you know it has to go
through approval stages and everything so the like you know
like the higher ups had to approve all of it by like uh so
like you know we were waiting for it and it was finally
approved by the higher ups last night and so huge shout out
on them for going on this wild ride with me uh to make this
all possible and i really hope everyone oh i hope everyone
has a good time and i will be personal i i will personally
message them to after this tournament just to make sure and
um and uh and we did it the hard part's done they're locked
in they can't leave now there's no more i there's no more
one last person they're locked in we're here we're ready to
play we're ready to game i'm so excited we did it i pulled
it off we pulled it off i didn't know this also before i
need to do one i'm gonna just do another shield thing it's
unrelated to apex legends but i figured it's related to my
stuff but uh but um last day to pre-order merch guys last
day we're gonna get my merch click on the link pinned in my
chat guys this is the last day you can join us during join
the stream check out apex and also my merch All right, I
will hop in the car.
I don't know if they're there yet.
I'm going to hop in the car.
Hello.
I'm looking for baby 2x.
Oh, hey, Altair.
Are you, did you try out the new game mode yet?
I haven't.
I was, I was sweet talking my baby 2x.
Oh, my 2x.
Your baby.
H.
Cog bruiser.
Hello.
All right, Altair has not checked out the, oh, Altair.
Sorry.
Yeah, he has not checked out the new game mode.
yet so he's going in blind i haven't checked it out either
wait you haven't what have you been warming up on i played
the games the last time i played this game the game oh okay
we're all getting on we're all getting on putting it up and
we're all getting you you're all trying the game mode
because it's all joining on apex we're all hopping on apex
right now i mean i wanted to say, Altar, it's nice to meet
you online, you know, for the first time, wink, wink.
Nice to meet you.
My name is Altar.
You can call me Regis if you want.
I've loosened up on that a little bit.
Heck yeah.
Sorry for that.
Altar.
You can call me Matara Khan of Independent and Resilient.
Double D's triple threat.
Oh my God.
Are you guys excited?
Are you guys so excited?
I'm so excited, Bird.
Oh my God.
It's finally here.
It's finally...
You are crazy, by the way.
I know.
I'm off on some coffee and two hours of sleep.
I've got this.
I woke up this morning and she still hadn't slept.
Yes, she still hadn't slept.
I just want to warn you, Altair, like the last time I played
Apex was legitimately six plus years ago.
I'm here for the vibes.
I'll listen.
I'm here.
I'm here to give you guys my body for the bullets and the
shields, but don't expect miracles, okay?
Natara, you don't have to aim.
It's literally, the game mode is like a fighting game.
You just...
Perfect.
You're just brawling.
You're just beating people up, Natara.
Don't worry.
We're going to be fine.
Quite honestly, you couldn't embarrass yourself more than I
do, so you're okay.
You're okay.
Okay, let's do that.
There's quite a little bar.
Anybody's embarrassing anyone.
It's me embarrassing myself during the 1v1s.
I'm going to get knocked out first.
Oh, wait.
I am my own tournament.
orientation matches.
Okay, I'm doing, it's not unlocked for me.
I'm running in.
I'm going in.
Wait, how did you work?
I played games, but then like, is she even going to be able
to play?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
It should be fine.
I don't even know how many orientation matches she has to
do.
Probably like one or two.
I was warming up on level four.
It should be, it's fine.
It's, it's, it's, it's, it's.
Listen, friends, as long as we have fun at the end of the
day, right?
We're going.
We're going to be okay.
We have 15 more minutes.
It's going to be okay.
15 minutes of panic.
No, it's gonna be perfect.
It's gonna be great.
It's gonna be fine.
It's so healthy.
We're so healthy.
We got this.
Somebody else right now is gonna be delayed.
I'm manifesting.
Somebody else is like, oh no, my computer needs a reset.
Okay.
Please manifest with me.
Everybody put your cloth together.
I'm the organizer.
I can start whenever we want.
At least nobody can say you rig the team to win.
Yeah, exactly.
I'll be like, hey, guys, we're going to have to start the
tournament at least 10 minutes later, guys.
You're like the birthday kid at Lasertag.
Yeah, it's my birthday, guys.
I need to win.
Happy birthday.
If you don't let me win, you hate me.
I won't invite you to the next birthday.
You hate us.
You hate, yeah, you hate Street Fighter.
Hey, thank you for the free points, by the way.
Yeah, no problem.
Which skins are you guys getting?
I already spent all my points.
I got the Chun-Li skin.
I got the one for Bangalore.
I got the one for Pathfinder.
And then I got one more.
I don't remember which one.
I don't know which one to use.
I don't know.
I actually, I love the Akuma one.
The Jibia Akuma looks really good.
I might use that.
Oh, but then his...
I don't know.
Yeah.
You know what?
Okay, I'm going to use the Akuma.
I have a silly question.
Is it because I never finished the games and I would just
leave when we got like far in?
so it didn't count the games for me okay that's why you can
okay you can play it and then you just kill yourself in the
ring okay perfect i'll do that allegedly yeah in game what
if what if i could give you a better option yeah talk to me
better option backpack wait i think mirage would be funny if
we ever get in trouble we send you out as a as a as a as a
prize llama oh yeah get her like we run we book it man yeah
no a great idea i mean and we can get james i'll go first oh
wait matara wait okay actually i have you yeah we'll take it
i'm in a fight i'm gonna fight okay i'm gonna show i'm gonna
share the game mode while while we wait because we can leave
whatever i'm even moving all right i'll show you the game
mode mode sorry game mode whenever all right also to my
sound guy i brought i'll tear it down a little bit hi sound
guy all right wait i'll tear ready up hello all right we
gotta give we got warm up for the warm up i'm rolling my
sleeve up all right i'm getting revived this is going great
this is the strat which i've noticed when you talk to me so
because you don't haven't played a game mode yet so if we
land on someone just pop left alt and then you're in street
fighter mode so left alt is where you you get into street
fighter mode and you start beating people up.
And there's like, and then there's like special alts for
your street fighter character.
I will recommend Dalism is the best one.
There's like several abilities you have to pick.
And Dalism is the best one.
Which ones are the easiest ones to do?
That one.
Okay.
Or Chun-Li.
It's that one or Chun-Li.
I would say the real one is the hardest out of all the ones
I've used.
Oh, I should probably change character.
I mean, it could be Ryu.
Oh, like a challenge.
I'd say Ryu is the hardest.
Akuma's one, his alt is hard to get because you have to
double click to activate his alt.
But the easiest is the Dalism and Chunli.
So those were the two I would play.
Is this game of just fighting people?
Yes.
You can shoot your gun.
I think it's more fun playing, like just beating people up.
But you'll have to...
You have to beat people up to gain more because it's like a
gauge.
So it's like a mini alt.
So you need to beat people up to have more to build up your
gauge.
Oh, just like in fighting games.
Yeah, so you can run out.
And when you run out, all you have is your gun.
I will not be allowed to use my gun.
So it's up to you guys to shoot people if we need to.
But I feel like if it's like gun...
If you have range, gun wins.
It's like, you know, if you don't have range, street fighter
wins.
I get it.
So sometimes it's yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
When you're close up, street fighter wins, basically.
Is there like an honor system?
You know, if someone doesn't have a gun, one person has a
gun, and they're like, come on, come on, 1v1, punch me,
punch me.
Technically, yes.
But it really depends on if the other two, I guess we could
crouch spam.
Like, it would be like a greeting being like 1v1.
And like, yeah.
So in this mode, there's respawns and stuff.
So even if you die, you can instantly respawn.
You just got to like, so like you don't have to worry about
like full dying.
That's good.
Like obviously as the round continues, the respawn timer
goes up.
But as long as one person is alive in the team, it doesn't
matter.
Okay, that's awesome.
I like that.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Come on, we need it.
That's a fun game mode.
It is.
It was so I've been playing it the last two days to like get
a hang of it.
Just to figure out like exactly.
you're my you're my leader on that then you're my you're
gonna go i know you're really great in-game leaders so
you'll be able to coach us really really well for this game
mode it's just beating i would just be like just beat them
up like so oh yeah and also there's gonna be coin like token
coin like trucks around at the toe you see a token truck you
pit it to get more ability points to refill your yeah you
can punch a truck yeah refill your ability i will say Pete,
she can put fences around.
So like when someone, if someone tries to beat you up,
they'll just get fenced up.
Like they'll just get stopped by the fences.
You're devious, aren't you?
She is.
She's just good.
I don't play Watson because I know a pussy.
I'm not a pussy.
You know what?
Respect, respect, respect.
I was like, I'll fight in your fences.
Me?
I will do whatever.
I will play whatever to me.
Okay, if you want to like, if you want to abuse it, you
should play Watson because they it's actually Really abusive
to you like you actually have to pull out your gun to shoot
the fences.
You can't do anything with it Um, also sound guy.
I've turned pull uh, I turned down both of them.
So let me know if it's better I can also sneak softer if I
need to I won't I don't want jump master.
All right.
I'll be jump master See you before I do this game Actually,
I feel like everyone...
Let me finish.
As soon as the ring...
Okay, I see the ring.
You said I can go into the ring, right?
Into the light.
I'm going to go here.
I want to beat some...
I want to go straight in.
I'll tell you.
I'm going straight in here.
Beat this guy up.
So, left alt is where you activate it.
You only have one meter, though.
Come in.
He's in.
I'm in two!
Oh my god, he's one.
No!
He was one!
Nice, I got my nice.
We got my life and I'm coming.
I got it.
I forgot, I was Mirage.
Are you in?
Are you beating them up?
Punch, punch, punch, punch.
Wait, I'm coming over!
I'm getting ADS or whatever, AD80.
I didn't grab a god Altair!
I went straight in to beat people up.
Give me a sec!
It's okay!
I'm used to 300 ping.
This is weird.
What's stopping you from just like running the whole time
with a gun in that game in that game mode?
Uh, nothing.
It's just more fun to beat people up.
But you said like you won't be able to have the gun because
you're too OP.
No, no, Street Fighter ability is more.
I feel like Street Fighter is more OP.
If it's close range, if it's close range, if it was not
close range, then the gun wins.
Oh, this is the guy.
Can you switch to O?
open the game mode for me i want to join them okay we're
good nice to oh my god a coin i'm taking this so seriously
i'm even gonna wear glasses during this so i can make sure i
can see real good oh i'm fucked oh there's another guy over
there oh no we're all dead i oh wait no you respond okay oh
shit we had eliminated i didn't realize you're all dead we
died we died all three of okay so can't let that happen uh
how'd you guys die tell me tell me um what happened you
don't want we want to talk about it i want to know i want to
know my aim down sights were stuck on on toggles i i might
have tried to 1v3 uh it might not have been the best idea
and then i better see you do that this whole tournament
bring the pain which we may have or may not have got don't
worry this is warm up to the warm up so we should be good i
immediately dropped pressed left alt and then the ran out
and i was like oh oh yeah you got land on someone you only
have one you have to land on i when i said that i i did say
you got a land on someone you didn't factor into the account
that i'm stupid right yeah that's i should have reminded you
to land on someone i feel that way too when people give me
instructions like okay but did you forget Did you forget
that we're streamer, ADHD, stupid?
All right, dude.
All right, don't worry.
The longer you stream, the dumber you get.
It's true.
I think I've definitely brain-rided myself.
Wow.
Me watching this guy from my death feed, maybe I'm not the
worst at aiming.
That's the spirit.
You know what?
Maybe I got this on lock.
Do you just need one game?
Is that it?
I think I'm yeah, I'm like I killed myself allegedly and now
it says awaiting recovery But since they won't be able to
recover me.
It'll end Wait, we have one minute.
We have it's fine.
We can leave whenever it'll be fine.
We didn't have It's okay.
Yoki, you can literally blame me be like Matara didn't
unlock her thing Like blame everything on me We'll be there
until until um Say I have really bad diarrhea.
Yeah, I'll say I'll say it in the channel I'll be like,
Matara is in the bathroom right now and she has a bad
stomach.
So we might need a bit.
The skinniest, most beautiful lady.
Okay, wait, wait.
So I'm not, okay, they will never catch us.
They'll never know.
They're not going to.
Wait, so I can technically leave them at you.
No, no, no, tell them.
No proof whatsoever.
I have no shame.
What are they going to do?
I did.
I already typed it.
I said you're in the bathroom right now and you have a bad
stomach.
But you know I'm live on stream, right?
So like...
It's okay.
What are you gonna do?
Fact check on stream?
They would know.
Okay.
I need...
I'm outing.
I'm outing!
Okay, make sure you're outing at them.
It's a complete orientation match to unlock.
I killed him!
Yeah!
You did it!
Okay.
He got up!
Legitimately might need like 15 minutes.
I think I need to do one or two more of these matches to
unlock the...
I'm so...
I played and I leveled up.
And I was like, okay, I don't, I didn't realize I had to, oh
my god, I'm so sorry.
You didn't realize what?
Yeah, I did walk the wa- Oh, I'm so, I'm so sorry.
I, I, I'm, I'm waste, oh my god.
It's okay, but I believe, I believe, but I'm literally
rushing my orientation matches.
Oh my god.
Tell them, tell them my diarrhea is really bad.
I did.
Don't worry.
I made sure.
Oh my god, I'm not going in there.
I'm not going in there.
I'm out there.
You're fucking crazy.
You don't get pulled out your gun there.
You gotta pull out your gun.
What gun?
I've been punching.
These fists are my weapons.
Oh, wait.
I need to remember.
I can't use gun.
Oh, shit.
I need to remember that.
I can't use gun.
Can I get somebody to check online how many orientation
matches I have to do to unlock the thing as a new account?
okay look i know i know i can't use gun but i'm gonna use
gun i'm wait this is so cheap oh fuck okay never mind we're
so good we're so good our team we're so healthy we're so
healthy what i'm really doing is i'm actually buying them
time to get better and rehearse you know okay but like i'm
so i i i believe we aren't gonna get in trouble are we doki
because of me i don't want you to i oh wait this isn't i
feel really really bad no it's okay if anything uh i'll tear
and i can start first uh die oh my god hi i'm okay i forgot
to pick up my actual moon oh oh it says if i play better it
completes it okay okay okay uh just kill everybody they're
all bots so it should be fine yeah yeah yeah i'm actually
gonna I ran into the circle this time, but this time I'm
actually going to do the thing.
All right.
Like, do you need it for a custom lobby?
it just, it doesn't even open the game mode for me, so.
Oh, then yeah, you might need that.
Oh my gosh.
People are pussies as well.
Oh,
people are fussy pussies.
We keep playing.
Okay, I'm sorry.
You gotta play Watson.
Yeah.
yeah okay perfect you just put fences I at this point I
think I just got a skin so it's perfect oh oh my god wait
that's not the character I thought I was playing whoa all
right where are they yes apparently I'm gonna I mean we
could ask if my manager is watching can you ask the admins
about it about like does she need to unlock custom or like
can they like grant her account special permission what is
going on up here you bitch you're so lucky what let me
actually wait doki can you try to see if i can join the hold
on let me see we've got lobby i have it open i have it open
now it's open now i don't know if they did it or not but
it's let me let's go let's go I'll beat up one more person.
I'll go into the lobby.
Let's freaking go.
All right.
You can say that I'm magically recovered.
Go in, go in.
And I no longer have that.
Okay, I went in and I realized that there's nobody here.
That's awkward.
But it's okay.
Oh, yeah.
What are you guys naming our team?
Oh, we're one and done.
Yeah.
There's two Watson.
We're going, oh my God.
I'm.
I forgot you could play more than one character.
Doki, Doki, I have a very dumb question.
How do I connect to the lobby?
So I'll give you guys a custom code.
Okay, let me set this up right now.
I see it.
Oh, you see it?
And then where do I go from in the game?
You go to private match and you input it from there.
Okay, perfect.
And then not on stream.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
And then you're good to go.
accuse you of like rigging this to win just i am proof
anybody that like after we win this and people watch my
stream they'll be like all right all right but do you think
this is a warm-up guys this is a warm-up game we should be
fine i'm seeing sure no no but sure for is sure for is
restricted to punch only he's not allowed to he's not
allowed to shoot his gut don't worry it's fine it's fine
they're only restricted it's fine it's fine their whole team
is named punch patrol we're gonna lose we're gonna get
punched okay it's so we can punch i just had a bad stomach
we can punch back guys
but leave in us.
Oh my God, the Heavenly Father.
He's really good at punching.
It's all right.
This is a warm.
Nothing matters here.
This is just a warm up.
Nothing matters.
Oh yeah, you can block with right click too, by the way.
Who's Crusader?
Who's B-Day?
What is it?
Yo.
Happy birthday.
You didn't say the O-Wo part.
All right.
Okay.
For integrity.
he was yes only one watson if i have to i will pull the
organizer card if i see more than one watson i would be like
royal decree royal decree yeah the empress has spoken i have
spoken you're only allowed to have one watson there would be
like such like new rule New rule!
If you're the ruler, can I be the the the really suspicious
like advisor?
I want to be the guy that's like He's just tricking me to my
lady That you're like don't trust them Can I be the spoiled
dog?
Go to Watson this time Oh, yeah, you're like my poison
tester You test like you're my food tester, you know, you
know eunuch that would be out there that would be out there
that's the royal our royal advisors usually you can't neuter
me i'm an idol so that's that's yeah that's your neuter
meant enough you know idols and monks we we share quite a
lot of uh things in common yep yep the um what is it called
um monastic lifestyle yeah there's a word for this um when
you what is it called in room world when your character when
your pawn doesn't need a fancy room ascetic ascetic ascetic
yeah yeah an ascetic believer the nerves are bonding wait
then what are you i am the opposite i'm a maximalist i'm a
i'm a general i am her spoiled dog that she feeds delicious
treats to and dresses and silks and i'm the unit yeah well
you you wanted to be the advisor you chose it you wanted to
scheme that's like unix do they can be both wise yeah yeah
that's that's usually it because like uh the uh anyone
that's close to like the emperor they get neutered you know
what let's compromise i'll take it can i be question can i
be a really fat dog like you can be the fattest little chud
that you want matara oh my god little chud that'll die of
heart problems yeah in my next life i want to be a fat dog
diabetes if you truly want won't it be one if you truly wish
that can be arranged and i want i want to have nice fancy
dog coats
finest silks or dogs.
I mean, at that point, how would the dog know?
Wait, but how would it?
That is a royal dog, right?
Yeah.
How does the cow know when to become mad, you know?
Exactly.
It's like when, you know how like sometimes people would
feed chickens chickens?
Yeah.
Yeah, how would they know?
How does my brain know when I'm cannibalizing another human
and developing kuru, you know?
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean, meat is meat.
Meat is meat.
are scary they're talking about cannibalism and it hasn't
even been 30 minutes cannibalism oh that's a record for me
see longest time i haven't talked about cannibalism it's
really funny you know how everyone's like oh um like male
male idols are so like you know like crass no no you put him
in a room with Doki and I, it's over.
I'm like, tell him I have diarrhea.
That's why we're late.
They believed it.
They're like, okay.
You weren't even the last one.
You weren't the last one in the lobby, too.
That's right.
I think I'm just scared of Axel being the third in this
team.
You're lucky he's Australian.
Is he more crazy than I am?
He's he's Australian, Matara.
That tells me a lot.
that's just a different level like you know he's actually
one of the few i haven't met yet probably because he's all
the way in straya yeah i mean they're like just it's like
like i mean they're a country that was made of criminals at
first so like it passes down don't get it don't get it gets
so long what it's true that's how australia started the
british deported it's okay it's okay guys guys i'm jumping
up the bullet with her um um eastern was basically they
shipped off a bunch of a bunch of um ladies that didn't have
uh families and and stuff and they worked the night and they
all got shipped to new canada which is correct and they all
she floated down in a bubble they were hoarse i got you joki
you're not getting counseled alone i'm here with you i'm
just being historically correct i'm is history wrong exactly
is history wrong i mean women of the night to okay but to be
fair colonize and populate is like not as like it's just as
bad we're the reason why the geneva convention was invented
Oh my god, I love being independent.
I love not being in a corporate space.
What I tell them about, is this right?
Oh my gosh, is this right?
We're going to get blacklisted.
We're going to get blacklisted from Hall of Stars.
My first and my last Hall of Stars collab is today.
Honestly, you're fine.
Last night, during How to Fish, we were talking about some
crazy stuff.
So don't worry.
Oh yeah, like what?
Uh, like what?
like what wait is your vod private is no wait wait is your
wanted to before before you say it is your vod private it
afterwards no okay then he's it's good to go yeah that's not
that bad i just don't think they saw um oh man please let's
just say axel wanted to put a hole in a fish oh oh how about
would it be would it make you feel better if we had why not
well like dokey and i go too far he has you want to make it
smaller?
Oh, I'm so sorry, man.
I'm so sorry.
The fish's mouth is already pretty big.
Yo, the fish mouth hole is pretty big, man.
I don't know.
Yo, this is the biggest minnow I've ever seen.
Oh, that got me good.
How about this?
How about this, Paltari?
If we go too far, just say fish hole, fish hole.
And then we're going to know to like bring it back down,
okay?
That's the same fish hole.
Fish hole, fish hole.
But I'll try my best.
So go wild.
I would love to not be blacklisted from hollow stars.
collabs after this first one.
I didn't realize you were asking Ursula Matara's back from
the bathroom.
From shitting?
From my fake shitting story?
I was like, where are we going to start?
And they were waiting for you to come back from the
bathroom.
Let's go.
And then my manager did message me like, hey, they're
waiting for you right now.
And I was like, oh shit.
She told me you're waiting for my I'm sorry to stop shitting
herself.
Actually, I told you they did.
Who's going to know?
They didn't check on it.
They're not going to know.
Oh my god, Team Fish Hole.
Let's go.
No.
Team No.
All right.
We need a Watson.
I can't play Watson because I only have like four characters
unlocked, by the way.
Pathfinder.
Mirage.
Team Fish Hole.
And you can use like all the abilities and stuff, right?
Yeah, you had to pick between.
There's four abilities and you pick between them.
I would say the Dalism and Chun-Li are the easiest ones.
Wait, quick question.
Yeah.
I still have it.
This was my first game.
So I'll just stick by you guys.
Yeah, yeah, just for now.
Maybe we should land somewhere safe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Again, I really apologize.
i i reu oh you can pick i see mb you can eat you can yeah
you can each pick the same one it's probably the one that's
really good you said or they're all really good it's the
best one because it has increased range ah for your punch
okay i'll do that yeah let's see where are the trucks i'll
go and then actually no i feel like someone's gonna hot drop
i'll go i'll go i'll all right nobody should be going to
oasis so cool oh my god you guys all have your feet up what
the heck jk we're gonna go oh but what if guys what if we go
here we we're fine nobody nobody's coming with us we have so
much time yeah all right so same as usual we loot and stuff
like that yeah you guys i just need to grab i need to grab
coins because uh you guys can um very dumb question but like
the same thing i pick up guns someone's here there's no way
there's no way someone's here yes oh my god someone is here
what the fuck someone is here i thought you were lying i
never lie here why would anyone land here okay you guys
might actually have to loot up i was fucking around.
All right, I got I have coins though.
All right.
Okay.
Wait, I need to change your setting.
Can you guys wait for a second?
Yeah, yeah.
Protect me.
You always want me to lock the door after.
I've noticed you're doing that.
I'll do that.
All right.
We'll be fine.
I think they're on the lock.
They're coming up.
We'll be fine.
Oh, we're going upstairs.
We're going upstairs?
Okay.
I'm following Regis.
Do you see them?
Yeah, they're on me.
Okay.
Oh my god, I didn't think things were gonna get so fast so
quick.
It's okay.
I got him.
Oh my god, you did.
I did.
Did they land with all the other people?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I can't believe they want to fight.
I can be the...
It's fine.
We all stick together.
If we all stick together, everything will be fine.
I need to change my settings.
It's okay.
All right, I'll guard you.
I'll guard you.
Don't worry.
Oh, they're running away.
They're running away.
okay they're not running oh my god oh my god oh i see what
you mean that in close range i got it i'm going down going
down going down
it's okay it's okay i got one i got one fine fine fine i'm
going in you're doing great you're doing great oh just just
die just die you guys just die just die just die just die
you guys change my setting i believe i believe it's all
right wait we got this everything's good i'm gonna get more
coins give me a sec don't worry guys as long as i'm alive it
should be fine yeah it's true so now are we just spawning
back to the same place and uh if you die just spawn to me
okay perfect yeah i'm just I'm grabbing more coins right
now.
Perfect.
I'm prolonging their game too.
I could technically kill them, but like, I saw that they
were Street Fighter players, so I'll let them live.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you know, I'm right, I'm bravely, I'm not running
away.
I'm just letting them live, you know?
Letting them play the game longer.
I love it.
You know?
So, with the little balls and stuff, the evil orbs.
I come with me.
We're gonna grab more coins for you guys so we can start
brawling.
Don't worry, it'll be really fun.
And then for the brawl, that's the left alt, right?
Yeah.
So we'll grab coins here.
I already have full coins, so you guys should get full coins
too.
Perfect.
And then by having full coins.
I did notice the guy when he went full brawling mode, he was
so good.
Yeah, that's why I like...
It's good to, if we all activate our braw mode, then...
We can just like beat one person up.
Okay, I don't need it.
So you grab it until you're full and then let I'm a tar you
can have the last two.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, that's that upgrades you.
That's the yeah.
Yeah.
All right.
So zone is this way.
Let's go to estate.
There might be a team there.
I missed Pathfinder.
He's so much fun.
All right.
So my all will be really over there.
Oh, I.
Oh, wait.
There's an ult.
there.
Do you want to fight them?
Someone's down.
Oh, all right.
Let's go.
Oh, they're up again.
Okay.
Perfect.
All right.
Let's brawl.
Are you brawling?
Oh, wait.
Raffle has been eliminated.
We have squad.
It's already been eliminated.
Oh, wait.
Oh, they're still fighting.
Still fighting.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm coming.
Mm hmm.
Go.
All right.
Get in fight mode.
Okay.
I got one.
One down, one down.
okay all right he's beating him up I'm in fight mode I'll
let you guys fight I'm gonna nice nice nice good job I'm
letting you guys fight I'm all right I'm running I'm bravely
running away I'm letting that oh my god I knocked down shirt
yeah I'm getting clinch I'm killing them oh okay just please
please out just bleed out okay yeah just bleed out just left
click left click all right don't worry you got sure for i
got sure for that's crazy you killed a pro gaming kill the
pro you're a professional okay look i would have wiped them
but i want them to stay alive a little long guys you know
you know honestly i would have wiped them too but i want
them to get cocky exactly exactly i wanted to wipe them but
like i'm i want people to have have fun and you know we
don't want to trample over them too fast exactly exactly i
could have easily wiped this team i i have to say any game
mode that makes me think that i got a shot is amazing i love
this game mode oh there's people here but there is like
there is shareforce yeah there is sure okay they're gonna
hear they're here i'm gonna go i'm coming up i'm coming up
They're coming up here.
I see them.
Don't worry.
We got...
One HP that guy.
Pathfinder?
Oh, we're getting shot from across.
Be careful.
Oh, we're on you so far.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
When should I use my stuff to assist you guys?
Like my ult and stuff.
Oh, when it's like...
So one of us is down.
Just use...
If they push us, all three of them, just put your ult down.
We're going to go to the ring.
So...
We got to go that way anyway.
How about this way?
your zip line yes i do place it here just place it here all
the way there all right we'll be fine because we're on the
zip line and it's harder to hit i attached that person's
growing wait you really did we're gonna need a bigger fish
hole yeah we're gonna need bigger fish hole for that one
That's so true.
People are dying so fast.
Let me be like, I mean, we could.
Oh, they're shooting me.
They're shooting me.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
They're so fine.
They're using guns.
Like, you're, you're alive.
They'll be fine.
Yeah.
Well, well, it's, uh, well, they're using.
Oh, they're shooting me.
They're shooting me.
It's fine.
You're actually getting kind of low.
You're up.
I can try and help you.
Don't worry.
Oh, they're coming.
I'm suppressing fire.
I'm coming.
Oh, shit.
There's a team behind us.
Yeah, we're in the middle of two teams, but it's okay.
It's fine.
We should be five.
I can use my old just tell me when.
You can, if they push you, just put it down.
If they push you, put it down.
I'm coming.
He can block.
Yes, you can block.
Okay, wait.
All right.
Just live.
Don't worry.
I'll, you guys.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, just die.
Sorry.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Man, I'm so glad you're taking it easy on them.
Oh, no.
I'm just taking it easy, guys.
just taking it easy destroyed i got finished i'm just taking
it easy you guys don't worry my children one of the
characters that actually has the really cool skins look i'm
letting you guys have fun it's really fun i have to say it's
so fun all right next fight i'll contribute i'll contribute
next way all right now i'm serious now she's losing 10 of
her power exactly i like how you respawn with the items as
well so you really are just here to like get your get your
punches on you know exactly
oh who you're shooting over here on ping yeah yeah yeah yeah
i see i forgot to equip the haduki oh oh
team over there watch out watch out oh yeah we're in the
middle okay yeah yeah all right we gotta go to the zone do
you have zipline oh oh oh yes i do all right okay they're
shooting us from every side just shield up and then we'll
zip to the ring yeah we're so fine and it'll be like a bra
and then how close do you wait to get to um activate your
punching like or when do you choose to gun or punch um i
would just i i would i would i would just like go i hear
people close i hear people close oh i mean I mean, you would
just punch.
I mean, if they're close by.
Fuck,
okay.
Never mind, I guess.
I couldn't dash it.
I want to get closer.
I'm getting closer to ring.
Oh, my God.
Are you punching?
Are you guys punching?
Yeah, yeah, I'm punching.
I'm literally here punching with...
I follow you.
I'm coming here.
I know where the people are.
Wait, where are they?
They ran away.
Just figuring in here.
Wait, I see them.
I see them.
They're right here.
All right.
Oh, we're in zone here.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, it's gonna be a bra.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
How is block?
A block is which button?
Wait, press.
Oh, wait.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
I don't want to just go in there.
I have no gun.
Locks and stuff.
When, uh, when do you...
Well, you just tie them in.
Is it right click?
Hmm.
I can't do anything.
All I can do is just stand there.
I believe in you too.
Yeah.
Do we want to just stay in this little place?
I mean, we could fight these guys if we want to.
How badly do you want to start pummeling?
Five squads left.
We got a prize at top three.
Yeah.
I want to be top three.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, we are at present top.
Wait, this is warm up.
This is warm up.
We don't even get.
Oh, yeah, right.
Let's go kill.
Go kill.
Fight, win.
Where are they?
Okay, right here, right there.
Right there.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm going in.
Oh, we're going there.
We're going in.
All right.
I got two.
Use your all.
I forget if it's Q or Z, I'm pressing all the buttons!
You're doing great!
You're doing it!
Oh my god, Altair, I don't even know if I can help you over
there.
It's okay.
They're not looking.
Are you mine?
Yeah, clickin' clickin' clickin' That's toxic.
Oh, I'm coming, I'm coming!
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine,
we're so fine.
Oh no!
We're so healthy!
don't worry oh no we're so fine come over here come over
here yeah yeah yeah i'm coming i'm coming come come come
come come come come come oh we're not in so we gotta go we
gotta go we gotta go we are going we are zooming we are
going yeah we're going we got this i'm safe on me safe on me
okay maybe not not safe not so safe on me now it's safe on
me okay
we're so safe
safe we're safe we're safe we're safe let's just chill for
it oh my god i'm approved we're so safe guys there's oh it's
showing down oh there's somebody here right here no more i'm
coming over are you saying safe because i oh wait we're safe
we're safe for all wait five squads for full brawl let's go
oh my god now i'm locked in i I'm like feeling it, Mr.
Krabs.
Are you feeling it now?
Okay, yeah, they're up there.
They're up there.
All right.
Whoops.
Do we go?
Yeah.
Okay.
Nobody left.
I activated.
I activated too early.
I'm sure.
All right.
I got it.
I told you.
Nice.
Okay, okay.
Okay, who else?
Who else?
You're going up.
Keep going.
Just keep fighting.
Keep fighting.
Fight mode.
Keep rolling.
Yes, got this.
Draw mode.
Just keep rolling.
Bro mode.
Yeah.
I don't know who I'm fighting.
Just keep shooting.
See, this is why I was chilling until the end.
This is why.
I...
Go for him up.
Matara, you're a pro.
You killed a pro.
You did it.
Oh my god.
I told you.
This game brawling.
This game is awesome.
Clicking your button.
And don't stop clicking your button.
See, but you didn't need a warm up, Matara.
Okay.
The problem is that now they're going to think we're good.
And now we're going to get targeted.
No, no, no, no.
Let's switch characters.
We got perfect guys.
Okay, I have a genuine question.
Where are the punches?
Do you just keep pressing one button?
It's literally just one button, right?
Yeah, it's literally left click.
Just in case I didn't want to know that there's like seven
buttons that are pressing one button.
I have a question too.
How do you block?
Right click.
The other button is right there.
There's two buttons.
There's two buttons out there.
Okay.
And there's Q.
buttons there's q wait okay four there's all there's okay as
you punch you can have all and you just press z it's
literally it's just z four buttons q is your special ability
and that i figured out i figured yeah yeah left and left
click is punch right click is block so i told you guys i
told you guys i was just i was just chilling this is great
i'm so happy i'm so happy you really just got to like jump
on people.
Yeah, exactly.
I was like, just pop it.
Just pop your all.
Just start punching.
Right, there's going to be a new lobby code.
I'll grab the new code.
Perfect.
Give me just one second.
I want to see if I can I can leave the custom match then,
right?
Yeah, you can leave custom match.
I just want to see if I can get one of the characters that,
how do I unlock the characters?
Where would I go?
You have to buy the belt.
Which one do you want to lock?
I can give it to you.
Any one of the ones that have skins, right?
Because I want to actually show the skins off.
know if i can gift it to you no no i have i have currency i
have two 900.
i want to unlock either bangalore or cami then yeah just
it's on uh oh i see it's like yeah yeah yeah so bangalore or
cami uh i think that's no that's not bangalore okay i don't
know and then cami is where cami is uh let's see um is
what's controller yeah yeah it's bottom right yeah yeah yeah
oh controller yeah yeah yeah all right so i'm gonna i
brought matara and i'll tear down a little bit more thank
you just a little i know i can't do doll sim because you're
actually really good with relocating let me see oh wait yeah
yeah you can get you we can get dollism too like one person
can play the character more than one character yeah but i'm
not nearly as a who do you think would be kind of easy for
me as a beginner um watson or oh vangalore oh chunley
watson's easier you just put your fences down yeah okay just
put your fences if someone if you we start fighting just put
fences around you because they can't punch you if they do
that so they'll get like but i want to punch them because
i'm better if i'm aggressive no yeah so then you put fences
on them and punch start punching them okay so they can't do
anything so they're trapping your chun lee the altar where
is she oh um is uh chun lee's uh well altar's hard actually
don't play okay then i won't
too because you're just popping barrels uh caustic has witch
skin though blanca oh yeah yeah that's blanca bangler is
easy too no bangalore is easy just pop smokes so then they
can't see you when if you if they're running into punch you
you pop your smoke and they can't okay then i'll do
bangalore maybe perfect uh whenever the code is there just
let me know oh yeah oh and i have to equip the skins hold on
i have to equip the skin sorry we have plenty of time yay
that was really fun and Axel.
Oh, cute.
I'll pop the code in the team chat.
See, this is why I was like, I was just chilling.
I was, you know, yeah, yeah.
Letting people play for a while, you know, letting people
live a little longer, you know?
Thank you for that.
Our savior, my hero.
Yeah, I wanted to make the game more exciting for everyone.
I hope everybody watching can see you.
that you can be the biggest beginner and still enjoy and
play this game mode yeah i mean i have the biggest beginner
and look at me i was letting i'll tear you just do all the
fighting and i wait until the final ring uh yeah yeah can
you explain to me so we keep respawning does it actually
penalize us or not really or no that's why like if you get
not just bleed out just hold left control and just die
because is there another is there a level of um response or
not no no as the timer ticks down, the respawn timer gets
longer.
So technically we can do whatever we want until the final.
Nobody respawns.
As long as one person is alive, that is fine.
That's what you're saying.
Perfect.
That's why I was running away because I was like, well, you
guys are going to die, so I'm just going to run.
Yeah.
Now that makes sense.
That's why you were like, oh, there's only a few teams left.
Yeah.
That was a very like old person friendly mode.
I'm just saying if anybody has been wanting to get back,
people watching know all I did was press buttons and I got
killed and I'm like, let's go.
The adrenaline's kicking in, right?
It is the adrenaline.
Mm-hmm.
So what are the rules on this next one?
This one is the tribute.
Okay, so you gotta protect you and only- No, no, no.
It's the boxing ring.
So I represent our team and I'll be doing a street fighter
1v1.
Let's go!
Okay, I'm honest.
If it's a 1v1 situation, we might be like, I'm really
fascinated.
She's doing it.
She always wins her 1v1s.
No, no.
Right.
In cheerleader uniforms, you and me cheering her on.
Let's go, Doki.
It's going to be rough.
I've had 1v1s in this game, but it was not pretty.
It was not good.
Ooh.
I wonder if I actually tower over you or not, because
Matara, I am six feet tall as a big bug.
What about you, Altair?
I am five foot ten and a half.
Oh, I love it.
So technically, if anybody wants to draw us in those like
little Q-leader uniforms, I am taller.
I'm just asking how you're quite accurate.
Make him even smaller and cuter.
Don't you dare.
Do it.
Oh, man.
I don't know who we're going to 1v1.
I'm worried, guys.
You're going to do great.
You're a gamer.
Oh, I'm nervous.
I honestly, I was surprised.
we didn't see the kill fear who died because i thought like
everybody was still alive i looked up i was like five teams
when when was there five teams i'm excited to go against
that punch kid i feel like he's really good at punching yeah
okay we might as well be the punch punch patrol we got first
place altair remember that we were first i mean matar did
1v1 and take down a professional i did a professional fbs
player i think i actually like but twice twice yeah i don't
know i think i saw my chat was like she got him i i honestly
was just pressing buttons like i need everybody to
understand that was my first time witnessing this game mode
and i think if you watch my vaude you understand it's my
first time doing this game see you out punched a shirt for i
bet he was like he's like but it's not working i have a
serious confession when i got into the game i didn't want to
say it on mic but i was like guys how do i activate my other
abilities we figured it out though we figured it out in the
end you did figure it out right yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
cute just start punching too many buttons exactly too many
buttons uh yeah all right the next game mode the boxing
royale for those for the viewers out there so each team is
gonna pick one tribute and which i would be the tribute for
team one and we're gonna play one set so it's best of three
each one v1 the admin of the server will start naming like
be like oh jokie versus gully or And we all watch around the
ring.
So we all land in the pathfinder ring, a boxing ring, and we
all watch it happen and cheer on our favorite player.
Who, for us, it's obviously Doki Bird.
But okay, well, when I'm eliminated, it's not going to be me
anymore.
But it's not going to be Doki Bird for next round.
But also, the fighter, the tribute has to farm their ability
gauge.
So you might have someone, another tribute, like beat you up
because they need to farm their abilities.
Queen, I, volunteer you may beat me up okay well you're on
my team there's no friendly fire so unfortunately i have to
beat up i have to beat up someone else on the other team i'm
so sorry guys i know how much you guys want me to beat you
up but unfortunately has to be on another random on a
different team oh going technically we won't take damage but
you can at least practice oh that's true that's true all
right so first in the ring will be punch patrol versus two
and a half Punch Patrol versus Oh Let's see Let's see how
punch patrol is gonna punch What if do you think they're
actually gonna have the punch kid go into punch?
Yeah it is punch kid I have access to like all the teams and
saw who their tributes were All right Oh so we are Oh we're
at match nine because we got to buy Let's go Yeah but
because we were We were Because we won the last game Because
the warm up was the seating as well so we get so we get to
watch it so we'll face whoever wins out of these two okay so
technically we cost you practicing right now that's true oh
all right let's see grip that pull and don't let go we got
you can do it trurkin spammers swag team fish oh team fish
oh all right guys
raging demons and glorp also gotta buy um we're raging
demons oh raging demons glorps perfect versus manta what an
edgy name raging demons versus punch patrol versus team six
seven oh the six seven skippity oh i know Six, seven.
Leave it to the Overwatch players to do the six, seven.
All right.
Perfect.
Bruce's.
Big Skibity Ohio in the house.
Is it weird to admit that I haven't watched Skibity Toilet?
I've never seen it.
I just, I'm cool and hip, so I like, I know about it.
I'm so proud of you.
I don't know how to tell you this.
We want to see in the world.
I'm, no, I'm just old.
I, I, yeah.
I'm just grown.
I'm ready to punch the audience end result end result and
end result you didn't watch it oh end result sorry grandma's
got bad ears yeah you gotta talk louder out here you gotta
speak her language you know you get her buzzwords going why
oh it's dukey bird dukey dukey bird i'll get her buzzwords
going not mine.
Yeah, not Doki.
What's your name?
Doki.
Oh, hi, Matara Khan.
My buzzwords are like oysters.
Why?
Whiskey.
I don't like oysters.
I don't know.
Really?
I don't like whiskey either.
More for you.
Perfect.
Yeah.
More whiskey for you.
More wine for you, Matara.
I'm looking forward to it.
What are you guys going to do?
snacks i've got oh my gosh are they waiting for me again i
hope not oh is that oh my god i used to love that when i was
younger it smells so bad and i love it it just has a stink
to it if that's what i'm thinking about right it's like the
shredded squid yeah it's it's pungent but it's so tasty it's
so tasty but it stinks it stinks so good guys they were
waiting for us again i oh no when are you gonna start and
then they're like please tell us when the start and i'm like
my bad my bad they were waiting for me to say start lamount
so sorry that's my bad i'm so sorry i lesbian from
participating in the no it's you're like sorry matara's back
in the bathroom uh i think maybe they actually are they're
thinking you're having a stomach problem so every game
they're giving you a bathroom break every game just be like
matara has really bad diarrhea good luck ducky all right
don't worry my matches don't start yet i can technically be
anybody that when you're hearing there is me in another life
oh how are you going to be the dog barking in the background
of a stream oh shit oh shit forgot to select okay i i didn't
realize i was on watson oh and i wasn't on the street
fighter skin oh no it's okay hey no no technically
technically it's still my skin it's a that is true let's go
um i thought i was auto selected on mirage for some reason.
Oh.
My bad.
We're doing perfectly.
Watson was the only one to equip the Street Fighter skin on.
Awkward.
It's okay.
Just say I have diarrhea.
Anytime.
I can't believe they're waiting for us again.
Oh, they're doing this because of me.
Is it?
change that skin change that skin this is so funny man they
love you I do genuinely wonder if we are the team that's
like laughing the most okay winning the most we should be I
don't know good I mean we got the first warm-up game done.
Dude, you freaking easy.
Oh my god, you're getting a warning.
We're gonna, they didn't say anything.
They didn't, they didn't calm.
Reminders, select the SF skin.
Yeah, but they didn't wear the fire.
It's fine.
Yeah, dokey bird.
Shame on you.
It's fine.
Everything's okay.
yeah i'm gonna write and be like who could be anybody it
could be anyone guys oh god snitch i wrote ready to an
advance just in case oh yeah ready it could have been anyone
you know didn't have to be me we did nothing wrong what are
you talking about dokey we're perfectly fine exactly
everything is good everything is okay awesome i'm a part of
a team i have a question what is sma two and a half small
two and a half smash it's because there's there's a
character limit so it's two and a half smash yeah so it's
like two and a half smash okay cool two and a half support
ticket sma stands for a simple moving average when it comes
to stock market stuff it's a it's an indicator used by
traders to see the moving average of a certain amount of
ticks.
Oh, my God.
Are these sports betting on us?
One of the guys accidentally bought the, they, so you can
buy, you know how you can buy the Street Fighter skins?
Yeah.
They bought the Street Fighter packs instead of the skins.
Oh, my God.
Wait, Doki, so you mean you started with the wrong character
and us being late?
It wasn't even us that delayed it.
It wasn't even us.
The guy literally had, No Street Fighter skins because they
forgot to buy the Street Fighter characters and spent all
the coins on Apex Street Fighter packs because it doesn't
guarantee the Street Fighter skins because there's other
items in the packs.
I'm sorry.
It's like because because Doki was very generous and she
gave us a lot of coins.
So we bought some skins.
It would be so funny if you gave that to people and they're
like, all right, let me spend it.
Gamble, gamble, gamble, gamble.
They're like, I didn't get any skins with the packs, guys.
I wonder like how jarring it must be to look at some other
teams that are like serious.
And then team fish hole over here.
It's OK, we're fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I'm more than fine.
I'm great.
i'm doing it we're gonna be it so healthy it's all right see
this wasn't even my fault i'll just i already pre-wrote
ready so like they can't be like we're waiting for you to
stay ready we're waiting for batara to get out of the
bathroom again oh again she's really doing it are you guys
good at fighting games i'm not good at fighting games i'm
not good at any game at thinking games games that require
you to think and roguelikes no you don't understand it's
getting worse the older i get the longer i've streamed the
dumber i've been getting well you just gotta counterat that
yeah like start reading more i guess no i want to get more
stupider i have lived a good life i'm ready to get more
stupid then you're gonna get alzheimer and dementia easily
Okay, okay.
Okay, but like, wouldn't that be awesome?
I'd be like living my best life.
Like, I would have a good life.
Would it be awesome to have Alzheimer's?
Every day would be your best day.
Okay, okay.
So real talk.
I did volunteer with old people and some of them did have
Alzheimer's.
And it's like, they're having a good day.
I guess.
I guess because like, you're having a great day.
Wow.
Yeah.
That breeds a whole entire.
entire like ethical conversation that we can start from
there don't worry we won't we won't team fish hole will not
go there we've went to enough places but no I know Doki it's
actually something I I really feel like I need to get
develop a skill or like read again or something because I do
I I appreciate the compliment but I have felt myself getting
stupider having less to say in conversations I don't
remember basic capitals or anything like that I feel like
people who cares about that though you know maybe pick up an
instrument
I used to be fairly proficient at the skin flute many years
ago, but it's been a while.
The white flute?
Why is that skin flute?
What's it?
Wait, what?
I looked it up on my company account.
Oh.
Wait, so what happened?
You're, you know, I was interested.
You were interested, Altair.
Oh, in the, oh, wow, Altair, you're interested.
I cannot be interested.
I'm a eunuch.
Remember that.
Yeah.
But you still have.
I love how genuinely you guys were like, Like, I haven't
heard of that instrument.
Delta, you still have a hole, just like a fish.
Doki,
I hope you lose.
Yo, did I say that?
I wanted to win.
Why me?
Matara was the one that got you.
I want to be nice to Matara.
If she does lose it, it would lower our threat level.
Wait, I should go a pathfinder, though, because I'm on the
specific ability.
Yeah, Regis, change.
Well, he doesn't have to.
You can play with whatever he wants.
We can both be pathfinding if you want to.
I'm already pathfinding.
Nice to him.
Oh, yeah.
You were so earnest.
Yeah.
We just all gotta figure something out.
Cause the longer you stream, once it gets to like five, ten,
10, 15 years, you're, you just started deteriorating.
Okay, Doki, we will shut up so you can focus.
No, it's okay.
You can stay wherever the fuck you want.
It's alright.
Alright.
I mean, our matches don't start until, like, a while, so
it'll be okay.
Oh, okay.
Perfect.
What have you been, um, what do they call it when, like,
enrichment activities?
Yeah, what have you been doing, Regis, for your enrichment
activities?
My enrichment activities?
Oh, I'll tell you, Jump Master.
I'll tell you, Jump Master, you're Okay, there you go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Gardening?
Let's go.
I've been doing a little bit of gardening.
Oh, that's sweet.
She's gotten to a really big gardening kick.
I love that.
I'm planting a lot of edible crops like cornrows, like
potatoes.
Planting a lot of edible.
And I've been reading Lord of the Rings.
Let's go.
Lord of the Rings.
That's a good one.
Yeah, that's good.
Okay, who didn't?
All right.
Who didn't select the skin?
We were right here.
Not me.
This time it wasn't me.
This wasn't on me, guys.
This wasn't on me.
This one wasn't me.
I'm not part of the That's not on me.
What if they blame you?
Again, just say I have diarrhea.
Again.
I personally DM'd everyone about the rules.
I apparently didn't.
I did.
Alright, I need to give my dog a tree.
I'll be right back.
oh what about our treats what about our snacks for your next
life when you become that dog learn very carefully just bark
a lot and you'll get treats right right both both both both
i love it he's like can i i love it he's like can i go play
another game what's going on who was what are you guys gonna
get for food later Oh, Saja crashed.
Wait, Saja is the tribute and he crashed.
Ha ha.
I've got some leftover myokuk, which is like a Korean, like,
seaweed soup.
All right.
Round three.
Yeah, myokuk.
That sounds delicious.
Mm.
Delicious.
Round three.
What about you, Doki?
What are you going to get for food after this?
I don't know, honestly.
I haven't eaten.
I mean, I did.
Actually, I ate.
a sandwich before this stream.
Honestly, I'm just happy that this tournament is starting.
It's finally going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Poor you.
You've been stressing.
I can't believe you put it all together.
I'm a little worried because it says waiting for players 27
out of 30.
And I'm a little scared now.
Yeah, because one of the people kept disconnecting.
No.
But it's okay.
At this point, we just swapped to we'll just go straight to
a wildcard game at that oh oh look let's hope oh it's
starting let's hope people i i'm just gonna say if someone
crashes if someone crashes again we again we go to next
match and then run the other one and don't stay there after
that because we gotta get this going.
We gotta get this party started.
40-20.
What are you having for dinner?
Or whatever you're having.
Honestly, chicken wings.
Some nice little Costco chicken wings in the oven.
Costco chicken wings.
And then when I'm done after this, I'm gonna have a nice
glass of wine because we're laughing so good.
The laughing, the chicken wings, the glass of wine, I'm
gonna be so good.
You can't treat yourself.
Yelp, yelp, yelp.
Did you hear that Costco's brief?
No!
What is going on?
I'm gonna be like, we are, we are running the next game!
I can't!
Full crash out, full crash out, happening right now.
I'm sorry!
Full crash out moment right now.
Tree fired.
thing pushed we are running the next mode i don't know
what's going on i'm gonna feel that do this again
i guess for me i'm just waiting but for you you're like i'm
about to play so it's so different
pushed to next, next game or something.
I don't know.
This is really fun.
Have we identified what the problem was?
I don't know.
Apparently someone's crashing.
We restarted four times.
I can't.
I wanna keep this going.
If we, I'm gonna say, if we're restarting like more than two
times, like I can't.
Yeah, worst case, we can probably do this game mode at the
end of the game if ever.
if anything if anything this game mode can be the end of the
the end of the tournament whatever well i guess it's snack
time for me well you can't snack on so what are you gonna
snack on admin oh yeah the punch it i forgot we we
completely i don't have executive decision or delicious but
you said no it's amazing i love that dried squid so much i
love it i thought i had may i add i thought i had executive
decision and then admin was like you don't have power
anymore i'm sorry i don't have it's okay just pick up the
dried squid with us
everyone else can watch streams ha ha stream watchers The
music has gone crazy.
Oh, my God.
No, I, so when I was a really, really young kid, this is a
little bit, I'll be quick.
Family story, my dad had a girlfriend from China, and she
would bring us Dried Squid.
And I brought it to school, and the kids bullied me hard
because it was stinky.
I know, it was so good.
Listen, I resonate with that.
I was on a travel soccer team.
So when we had to go to a different state, for soccer teams
we would we would take this big coach bus right everyone had
their ds's they were playing mario cart oh everyone brought
their snacks you know their crackers and all that stuff i
brought these korean snacks they're like little uh uh sea
animals crackers and they just really really savory but
apparently they stink a lot so i got bullied for that they
put it they put me next to the toilet the next to the toilet
that's crazy the stink in one place man that's crazy that
happened no matter how pungent it is if it's tasty well i
mean i'm a big not to enjoyer like genuine not to like
unironically unironically i always have the packs of frozen
uh not to in my in my freezer and then i put like every few
days i put a few of them in the fridge every morning with
like the mustard oh and a little bit of hot sauce oh it's so
good i love stinky food i gotta i gotta say i'm not i really
stinky food have like definitely a lot of taste to it but
particular flavors to it i'm not locked in anymore i'm it's
gonna be okay i can tell i can tell when you stopped
freaking doki doki listen to me you've got the skin of a
killer doki I do.
It's been an hour.
I just feel bad.
I just feel really bad for like the people who are in the,
like, you know, they took their time out of their scheduled
private tournament.
They're still waiting.
Yeah.
Okay.
May I remind you?
May I remind you that like this is a dream job for so many
people.
May I remind you that like, oh, somebody took the day out of
their Twitch stream to spend a few extra hours.
You're giving everybody a chance for a Twitch viewership,
cool YouTube video, new freaking exciting event, free stuff.
skins like oh it took you an extra hour out of your day boo
freaking who please don't worry about that anybody that like
would give you for that is yeah it's also like the viewing
experience too you know the viewers are like oh well they
can just go to our bot is funnier they watch live stream
they got patience it's okay it's friday night like of course
they're gonna be chilling like to worry about it.
I know you worry about it and I understand.
I would, you know, in your case, like... Yeah, I just want
people to have a good time.
Aw.
I just want everyone to have fun.
Like, this is a for fun event.
Let's go.
But, please win me some money.
Alright, here we go.
Well, it's just me.
It's just...
Please win me some money.
I already used up all the skills.
in our warm-up game.
I used up all our luck in the warm-up game, guys.
I don't know anymore.
Oh, I guess I swear to God.
Enough time has passed.
It reset.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, boxing ring is here.
Oh, I need you to lock the fuck in, okay?
Oh, I swear to God.
If we win enough money, I'm going to Japan with this money.
Really?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Hi, fighter right now.
I mean, yeah.
All right, you guys just say go here and I'm going to go to
the truck and farm some ability points.
Okay.
You might some people might start punching you for ability.
So get ready.
Wait, I'm accidentally in the ring.
Okay, I'm not in the ring.
You get out of the ring.
How do you eat?
I don't remember.
Oh, my God.
Nice skin.
all right i'm full ability gauge now oh my god we made it we
fucking we made it we're finally here no disconnect no
disconnect we're here we're finally here all right who's the
who are the contenders
Are they farming?
You better win.
This young man wants to go to Japan with this money.
Okay, there's a lot of...
Guys, we have like five chances to get the money, so we're
fine.
We're fine.
Doki, Doki, I need this money to pay my rent.
Doki.
You need this money, pay your rent, and then you have bigger
problems to worry about.
I just moved to my parents' basement, but I also need this
money to pay my rent.
Are they, are they?
Okay, one person's in the ring now.
Oh, two people, oh, wait, never mind.
This is me.
All right, I only see one person.
Wait, nobody's in the, where are they?
Where's the two people that are gonna fight?
Come on, fight.
Where's the best of you?
Oh, this is a great view.
I have a good view right here.
Oh, from you, from where you are?
I wanna see where you are.
Are they giving them a pep talk?
I wonder if they're giving a pep talk or some shit.
Oh, maybe.
Hey, if you get me in the face, like, that's it.
Oh, wait, this is a great viewing experience.
What the heck?
Oh, nice skin.
Yeah.
Oh, you could just be like, please.
Oh, I'm tired.
Tell them.
Good luck.
You're like, oh my god, the admin was do not tell them stuff
without getting my permission
They're like, don't even talk, Doki.
I was just like, I'm just trying to keep.
It's your tournament, but they took everything from you now.
They're like, uh-oh.
I got the hard stuff.
I had the hard stuff then.
Now I'm just, uh, now I'm just here.
Take it easy on her.
She's just a little guy.
Just a little guy.
I thought executive power.
They're farming off of all.
How do you emote, by the way?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
When are they starting?
I'll just be like, please tell them.
Please give, tell them when to start and then do countdown
as we are waiting.
I don't know what's going on.
Get in there!
Oh, are they in?
They're waiting.
He's waiting right now.
Are they farming?
I think they're just farming ability gauges.
Oh, they're charging.
They're charging their abilities right now.
I'm so excited.
They're all just beating each other.
Okay, one guy is ready.
Where's the other guy?
Do we have one guy?
Where's the other one?
Where's the other guy?
Where is he?
Get in there.
whoa whoa whoa what's happening here they're getting ready
to charge didn't mean to do that all right that punch kid
has three kills now he's he's so close he's so revved up
soon get in the ring the guy's just like where is I knew he
was gonna do I knew he was gonna try to punch me off of the
thing Man Get charged up We're waiting for the first two
that get charged up.
It's taking him a while Taking them a while to charge up.
That's fishy Guys, please I'm trying to enjoy the show,
please.
I don't even know who's the apex predator is this lobby yeah
oh there is i just thought i thought that it would people
would charge faster but i guess that's a little oversight on
my head all right oh wow
it's okay i'm sure that once everyone's all charged up it'll
go smoothly from there oh that was so cool is everybody
charged up oh oh don't still still that one person every
time i felt i've where is he where i want to see the names
if only i've admin powers to see the names right i have like
where are you oh wait they're all in they're in they're in
oh he's in he's ready okay wait there's two people in wait
who are okay well then um there's four people in i i don't
know i don't know i don't know they're fighting they're
fighting can you can you do a countdown when they are in or
are they still charging oh i'm seeing oh they're fighting
they're fighting they're fighting no no they're charging
they're charging they're charging oh there okay i'll stay
around i want to watch though is that it oh the wrong guy is
in and he's afk which one is it just fight around and fight
around the afk guy fight around him wait why can't they just
kill the afk guy wait that's so true but Mosh pit.
Just fight!
Who can just...
Kill him!
Eat his body!
Oh wait, they're fighting.
Wait, they're actually fighting.
They're just posturing each other right now.
Eat him up, eat him up, eat him out.
Just fight!
Kill him!
You can kill him!
Okay, all right.
Get him out!
There we go.
Now fight!
Kill!
Oh shit, they're going.
Oh my god, they're running away!
He's...
Oh, he's trying to ult!
He's trying to ult!
Oh my god, he's teleporting.
What the hell?
Oh, they're punching, they're punching.
Oh, he did it!
Thank god!
Thank fucking god!
Oh my god!
Let's go!
Punch kid!
Oh, of course you'll punch kid.
Punch kid won the first round.
Oh my...
I believe This one should not have been the first game It's
fine I'm having fun I do feel bad for you The nerves must be
100% I just I just didn't realize how Oh he got the finisher
Oh he got the one shot And the queen No How did he hit that?
So with the alt, if he hits it, it's a one-shot.
Ah.
And he hits the alt.
It's very scary to dodge.
I should have picked that.
I forgot about that.
It's a mystery about the ultimate.
Nice.
Punch Kid.
I think Punch Kid advances at that point.
Yeah.
Punch Kid wins the punching.
Good job.
Movement.
That one?
No, it's the Akuma.
Ah.
It's the Akuma one.
All right.
I we did it is that not the end is there another where's
next one well I'm not at admin oh who's next who's next he
won he left the ring
maybe he's recharging I like how we're all just walking I
just wrote Perfect vs.
Team Manta.
Come on, Team Manta.
Oh, they're going in.
She's ready.
Here we go.
Alright, fight!
Fight!
Oh my god, this goes so fast now.
It's going so much faster.
Oh my god.
Alright, come on.
Start the game.
Start- I won blood!
Oh shit, whoops.
all right they're sizing each other up they're sizing each
other oh oh my god throwing abilities blocking oh oh they're
going at it oh yeah get out of here whoa that's so cool i
thought this was a street fighter tournament no it is it is
it is are you not seeing the street fighter six right there
yeah do you not see the ring oh zuni takes match one or
three let's go all right next up
next up
oh whoa hey i'm part of the whoa you're not farming me i
Oh, you can't farm a tribute.
Well, that's not real, but...
Do you want my respawn thingy?
That is funny if they're, like, grieving you.
Here, let me give you my auto-respawn.
Do you need my auto-respawn, too?
No, I'm good.
I just need one.
There you go.
I think they're trying to farm off of...
Yeah, he, like, left after they fired.
They should have maybe made, like, the tribute stand on the
side you know or something the what oh ow yeah they're
farming yeah they're farming uh the coins right now yeah
they got pad you got pad coins right now wait i'll get get
over to you it's fine if i don't have another self-revive
after this yeah it's fine because you'll just okay you'll
just respawn all right here we go a duken a duken whoa oh
they're just blasting it to Whoa!
Oh, Zuni 1.
Nice.
I think that's a 2.
Yeah, 2v2.
All right, next.
Now it's going fast.
I think like when people already farmed, it should be faster
now.
They died so fast.
Holy shit, look at the timer.
Where's the timer?
Oh, whoa.
Oh, zero.
Over.
I'm dead.
Who's next one and oh wait, it's me.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I didn't realize it was me.
All right.
I'm ready.
Let's go.
Okay, if I lose.
If I if I let's go.
Do you want us to be quiet or to talk?
What helps?
What?
Okay.
oh my gosh i'm trying no i got it we can press it yeah oh my
god that's awesome
let's go don't come she's the number one she never loses any
one v1 we got this pep see this is how you do it fast all
right there's a coin here I won't take it so the other guy
can grab it.
That's fine.
I'm ready whenever.
I'm gonna make this fast.
I got this.
Let's get it too well real quick.
I'm waiting for the start.
Start whenever I'm so ready.
Alright.
Got it.
That's a hard job.
Good.
target no i got finished no i forgot about this was the guy
with the finisher this what this guy had a finisher and i
forgot you got this i forgot the alt oh my god wait wait
this means he can't use it again right i don't know that's
the thing i think he can have it whenever i need tp the
moment he does it i forgot i forgot about the stupid alt no
key ways no i no i lost wait no i lost she got like i lost
she got exterminated one to one she got vaporized vaporian
eyes i mean whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it must be hard to
see who's who i it's one to one
You got this.
Whoa, whoa.
Rig.
No, I don't want to rig this.
I don't think the ammo is lit.
So I want it to one, don't you lot.
Oh, no, no.
He has all now.
He has all because I have all.
Oh, no, this is bad.
You got this.
But I might get one shot here.
I might get one shot.
My team is one and done.
no where is he where is he he's not here where is he yeah he
like left the he like took he like lost one and was like oh
jokie one i guess she did all right no it was a it was a
pathliner that's why you got confused where did he go where
did he go he actually left what where did the guy go I'm
gonna yell at Zuni stop wait where which one is he oh punch
patrol we're in they're bullying me you're getting thrown
around she's bullying me okay all right here we go all right
thank god okay this is bad for me Doki.
Whoa.
Let's go.
That's actually right.
You're going to use your stupid all I'll use my own.
Now get out of here.
Let's go.
All right.
There you go.
I'm done.
I finished.
Let's go.
Wait, you did it?
Doki, they beat me up.
I couldn't see you actually win.
They beat me up.
If they're going to use the one shot, I'll get that guy out
of here.
Basically, Doki flew.
up in the air shot a couple of fists of fire yeah he went oh
amazing she got two out of three let's go yeah let's go
you're my hero so you can spam his versus six seven oh shit
oh i'm getting beat up now too yeah right oh beat up first
the thing is when you're in the ring you're fully charged
all the time so it's like
oh okay they don't have to beat us up right now they don't
have to if they already charged up they don't have to charge
again six seven is far and this morning i'm actually gonna
take this as a pee break so give me give me a few minutes
okay i'll tell you like how you're typing chas of everybody
could see it but it's just you're
No one could see it.
They're just typing it to us.
See now that I see people using, like if they use alt, I'll
off.
If they don't use alt, I'll play fair.
Here, I'll let them farm me.
I'll let them farm me just to keep it going.
Oh.
Wait, wait.
What's going on?
Oh, I'm screen tearing.
no is he still farming what has he been doing has he been
like practicing while the fight was going on like they're
starting to start oh they're starting oh my god oh good
walks oh oh one shot done one and done so don't keep it i
gotta ask yeah what was it like in the arena we were super
locked in and give them a fight?
Well, I was going to give them a fair fight and I was going
to, you know, show them like, you know, pure, active pure
skill.
But then the Akuma popped out the one shot and I was like,
oh, it's that type of fight now.
All right.
Well, I mean, if that's how you want to play it and that's
on you, you know?
So what is your opinion on one shots?
I think the people who use one shot should be taking out
back in.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Thank you for the interview.
We'll catch you later after this, after this ad read.
And have, you know, head into a nice restaurant, you know?
Woo.
We're safe.
I don't think people realize you don't...
Oh my god, he's trying to farm as much as possible.
It'd be funny if I just take the coin.
Thanks.
What did I miss?
Oh, they're going in.
They're going in.
He's ready.
one guy one one guy lost oh nice oh shit guys you're doing
yeah that's why
oh yeah he beat him i wonder if that's a dq if you're like
off the ring but i don't think so i think well i mean he hit
him it's like sumo they're gonna sumo wrestle this is so
close what the fuck are you still fighting holy shit oh that
was one to one right now wait that was actually a pretty
good fight not a lie do you think these two people are like
fighting gamers you invited a couple um i know curry is a
fight i think it's curry versus sang sang's an apex player
and curry is a fighting game player that was actually close
i don't know like here's a little bit different i don't
think i yeah it's like i mean you killed sure for it matara
like yeah because i'm the apex predator gamer are they
finding right now yeah let them fly curry's for all right
you find me where is he i got some little rice crackers
because i was so inspired by you snacking on stuff yes it's
so good fight are they fighting now no but that guy's just
chilling oh he's practicing his hadoken wait akuma was a
secret boss what do you mean maybe the character akuma was a
secret boss and street fighter back in the day no cool thank
you for the name like akuma he's definitely not a good guy
you know i'm surprised he's a big demon I think I feel like
I feel like if when you have gold we can go in the ring you
can you just need a farm once because I just had to farm
once and I was good to go even after I died but it was only
because I'm a big gamer I only noticed that after I go in
the ring so oh
because you're a big gamer maybe I'm just gaming where is
nobody compares oh they're here wait you didn't hear never
mind Where is he?
I don't see him anywhere.
Where is he?
Is he after all of us?
Where even is the guy?
I don't even see him anywhere.
I just see the main guy in the ring.
Are they giving him, like, a pep talk?
Like, he's there like, you got this, bro.
Just remember, he always used A, B, A, B, block.
Like, giving him the, like, that's what his patterns are
like, bro.
up tilt him up tilt him just remember all right now that i
know i just thought this would go a lot faster but it's okay
it's okay the other games would be faster just vent out some
energy by jumping oh wait they're in they're both in no
that's just the same guy was seeing him run around oh is it
him no that's not him i'm gonna use this joke that akuma is
just a bear no instead of demon it's good i like it akuma
it's just a bear oh kuma my favorite one-piece character
second player oh they're fighting with brawl favorite the
girls are fighting oh oh my god out of the ring out of the
ring that's like crazy oh he's finishing
listen the announcement came before the death that's crazy
you attach these pads everywhere even outside oh my god
these hands are rated e for everyone exactly that's insane
swag champions versus perfect no great name all right well
one got pre-farm oh two above there already pre-farm
mad lads the mad lads they did it they pre-farm they got
prepared they're doing it
all right all right oh he's having one shot he missed he
missed the one shot see i that's what i see i knew if i know
like what what character do they what billy's they're doing
oh whoa stupid question so when i was fighting people i was
just kicking and punching them yeah how are they throwing
balls of energy um cute are they clicking other buttons it's
cute yeah yeah so that way so that you lied to me when i
said four buttons yes i said four buttons there's qz and
left right oh i was i was only pressing left button i mean
you were still beating people up though i was but then okay
i did much more than just block and I said four yeah yeah
you did okay so there is you and Z as well okay you were
nerfed that entire time yeah but you don't fear an FPS pro
yeah with that yeah you be an FPS pro kicking oh oh well
it's a good thing I know before the actual real matches
right oh they're fighting they're fighting yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm getting their stride like the Q and then the black
one is well it's different character abilities like they're
playing different characters so both this queue they're just
ranging they're they're like mps right now i love it oh
she's alting she's alting oh she hit it she hit the oh oh my
god it's one to one now no she actually hit the oh that was
funny oh man that was a that's a fast set see now that i
know there's all I just got a cue out of it.
I just got TP.
Because it's easy to dodge.
The ult just seems to get moves forward in a straight line.
You can move it around.
But it's hard to hit it.
That's why I don't like Akuma's abilities.
I think like Dalism is the easiest one.
That's why I play her.
Chin Lee is easy because she's all so fast.
But her all is hard to use.
Well, as long as you win.
Yeah, as long as I would.
But then after...
Okay, guys, after we win, we're fucking around, though.
Absolutely.
We can't have them be like, wow, Doki rigged this entire
tournament.
I don't think anyone will think this.
Doki, I am here.
Matches, like, two hours into the tournament being like,
okay, wait.
You told me there's one button, but clearly there's more
abilities than what I've been using.
I don't think anybody will think you rigged this.
The warm-up, I wasn't even trying.
I will say I was absolutely not trying during the warm-up.
Just running around, letting you two fight.
it was literally it was all it was literally a 2v3 every
time until the final ring and then i and then i went sicko
mode wait i thought i thought you were taking me easy on
them oh my god saja wins wait saja beat a pro let's go saja
she beat a pro oh shit it's glorbs time it's golly's time
goes my friends
He's unleashing his inner beast.
Oh my god, I hope Gully wins.
I don't know who's in the other team because I don't know
the names.
It's a good thing I have my glasses on.
I don't know who's.
Oh my god.
Beat him up.
Chun-Li wins.
All right, let's see who won.
Get him up.
Who was it?
I'm going to put you guys on the side a little bit.
Yoink.
A praise.
No, Galilaz!
Galil!
Unleash the beast!
We have a challenge!
Go Gear 5!
Unleash the beast!
Galil!
Yeah, ba-ba-ba-ba!
Ba-ba!
Oh, shit.
Wow, what a heavy hit.
Come on, Gully.
Oh, he's got the one shot.
Wait, who?
Wait, was Gully the one shot character?
Oh, my God.
I can't tell.
It actually looked like a big, like, spider devouring.
Yeah, that's crazy.
Oh, no, Gully.
Gully got one-shotted.
Gully got destroyed.
No.
Feels bad, man.
He didn't let his inner beast out.
Gully, you had one job!
Oh, fuck, it's my turn.
Okay.
I don't know who it is.
My game just crashed, but I think it's fine if I'm not in
there.
I'm not gonna...
We'll give you like...
okay i don't know which one this guy no no it's fine it's
fine i'm just gonna spectate off of you guys because my my
game just crashed but it didn't tell me anything i don't
know okay maybe because i like all top for a little oh my
god wait this guy isn't seeing oh my oh shit i might be
okay i understand now okay i understand now you you harness
the power okay i have to Okay, I have one round to figure
this out.
I might have to.
Oh, do I pull up?
Guys, guys, do I pull up the ult?
Do I pull up the ult?
Pull up the ult.
Come on, Doki Bird.
Do I do it?
You got this.
Do I do it, guys?
I need your permission.
Please win us some money.
Take them off.
So Altair can go to Japan, please.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we're dead.
We're dead.
You hate me.
It's okay.
It's so melting bad.
Okay, um, guys.
That guy has destroyed us.
He destroyed me, guys.
Okay, don't we try again.
Go and get your gauze.
It might be.
Um, guys, I might have got destroyed there.
He might have read me perfectly the moment I opened it.
No, no, no, no.
Don't say that.
Guys, um, you might not.
He found out that I don't block.
He is.
Altair, I found out that I don't block Altair.
I'm so sorry.
No block, I don't block.
I didn't realize.
I totally realized.
I figured it out that I know.
Wait a second.
I know Doki Bird.
He never blocks.
I know her.
I might have found out that I just left.
Did you throw true or false?
No, I just started punching and he just threw 20 fireballs
at me.
Oh, okay, that's what you crashed.
But then when I reload it, I'm like back in the match as if
it's no problem.
Oh, yeah, yeah, it works like that.
Because it's a custom lami.
That's my best.
He knew the three buttons that you press.
And he pressed four.
You know, he knew that I have a block button.
He knows that the block button unbinded.
Unbinded?
How is it unbinded?
I don't pay for it.
pay 40 to block guys come on i yeah facts hey i won my one i
won my one that's all that matters see that's a dps mindset
right yeah i won my one which was the first match oh maybe i
should have went projectile maybe projectile is strong that
thing followed you like i know i needed to block I am proud
of you, Doki.
I think you did a phenomenal job, okay?
And I'm just saying that because I just learned.
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's one to one.
Yeah, choose your name, one and done, guys.
We won and done here.
As our captain, you really...
One and then actually done.
Team Pitchhole, come on.
You really showed them.
Yeah, right, guys?
them one and done one and done how good we are i'm not gonna
lie i am really excited to go and punch some people some
more it was our second game but i already forgot my own
format i'm so excited event two oh melee and abilities only
so we can punch people but it's not the street fighter
punching is regular punching okay here's the plan this guy
yes here's the plan we run jibby okay and then which
character is that um it's akuma okay okay and then watson
and then then watson and then uh horizon okay i have watson
unlocked if that's okay so which one would be the easiest
for one for me to do uh-huh if we make it to the end game or
ash or ash wait we could do ash too because we can just like
run into people and just start punching people like if we
see someone we'll just start punching and when you say like
we're not using the game ability so we're not using the alt
punch we're just doing regular melee wait one oh wait am i
where are you third place oh wait we're fighting for third
place okay let's go come on donkey bird okay come on i'm
back in i'm back in i'm back in i'm back in i'm back in i
didn't realize i'm back in okay it's fine good luck Oh.
Nice block.
Thank you.
Oh, he's ahead of me though.
Oh, where it might be fucked, dude.
Nice.
Yeah, oh my God, what HP?
You are my hero.
Yo, got something.
All right.
Nice.
You are my hero.
Only you can do this.
Only you can save Lego City.
This is it.
this is it this is so funny somebody's like is there a new
outfit today because i wrote cyber athlete debut and it's
like no this is me being a cyber guys guys i learned how to
block guys please block it out i figured it out i figured it
out i figured it out oh wait do we win anything from you
having third place yeah i think it's third okay then i want
you to have third place all right honestly i didn't even
farm i went straight in I had like three bars and I fucking
sent it.
I don't need a farm.
Is this neutral?
You still have time.
That's it.
That's my lead.
See it.
That guy's a tryhard.
I fucking went in.
I had three bars.
I knew how to finish the job.
I knew how to finish.
I'm so proud of you.
We're doing it raw.
I'll show you guys.
Somebody killed me right before you're mad.
I think I'm like the oh, that's the guy that's farming guys
I I show see the thing is everybody's playing projectile
Except for me.
I do have projectile as well.
Okay.
Good luck.
You got this you got this you got this Nice
Oh Okay, it's so close.
Oh, it is She's blocking.
I'm so proud of her.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Get out of here.
That dodge was insane.
Oh my god.
Let's get the fuck out of here.
Projectile shit.
I told you.
I learned from my mistakes.
Let's go!
Okay, wait, wait.
Before I get excited.
Uh, yeah.
How much of a Japan trip are we winning by you placing
third?
I don't know.
I think it was like $900.
It's like, what?
I want to make a trip to like a week in Japan, a week in
Korea next year, so.
So, Joki, you better get to winning.
I was planning on doing it anyways.
Don't worry.
It's so good.
Thank you for winning.
Oh, my God.
This is the best day ever.
I did nothing except have a good day.
And Doki's winning us money.
You're welcome, guys.
All right, guys.
Thank you, Doki.
You're the best.
You're welcome, everybody.
I did my best.
See, look at everybody doing pussy projectiles, fam.
Look at that.
Come on, guys.
I went straight in.
I TP'd.
Oh my god, I'm sorry, but calling it pussy projectile is
kind of a boss move.
Why are you casting your pussy projectiles?
Exactly.
I don't even one shot.
I don't even use the one shot ability.
I fucking dodge that shit like paper.
If that was in there, I would have been absolutely using
every trick I had in the book.
I would not be trying to count a game.
There we go.
Already?
Oh, they're going straight in.
I didn't even fucking farm to.
Oh, they're hard.
Oh, they're blocking.
So they're just...
Look at him.
He's just spacing him.
Like, he's going.
They're spacing him so hard.
He has the projectiles.
Pussy projectiles.
He's just running away.
It's like a father.
and sun playing catch uh they're just running away who want
i don't go ahead even tell they're both watches oh side oh
wait it's one it's always so close with these two whenever
they go behind the big dome i'm like guys please yeah
they're like zoning yeah i feel bad though for the ones who
got knocked out first they have to watch with sea
projectiles to the end i'm glad place third do they have
what it takes let's find out yeah do they do they have what
it takes do they know so you don't take any damage when you
block no but it's like a cooldown there's a cooldown to the
block yeah yeah you gotta like time it for when you see them
fly into your face yeah oh my god they're fighting it out I
mean it's um whoever wins oh my oh my god the shuriken and
then the whoa oh oh wait did it who won they're both watches
I can't tell they're both the same oh saja got eliminated
sangha's your champion that was good job yeah Kill him!
Spammers!
Okay, he's the third place, right?
Yeah, I got third for us.
I got third.
Yeah, but Sang is the one who keeps the leader.
So it feels good that like he's the one who won the whole
thing.
Yeah, he beat me.
But he was crazy.
He beat me when I didn't know how to block.
And now you do also play.
I did.
He taught me, you know?
I downloaded his playstyle and it's like an actual street
fighter where everybody is Ryu.
and i'm the one person that is dal what it's like 20.
um oh my god it's over we got third guys thank god we never
did honestly you guys are there you did awesome and i did to
get us we worked hard we really like this was a team effort
for exactly your your motivations kept me going you know
your motivation all right we and go to the next lobby.
They never, they'll never expect this.
Honestly, we really put in the work.
I just have to say that was such good.
Without your motivation and assistance, I would have never
been able to pull this off.
It's true.
Remember that, everybody.
We were doing that.
Exactly.
It was a power of friendship.
Yeah.
We.
Mm-hmm.
I just want to say, Doki, I worked really hard that last
one.
I mean, to be fair, you guys did worry like why didn't you
block you guys gave me like the motivation when you're like
Why didn't you block Doki?
And I was like, oh, we were like kind about it.
I do have block.
I Were we done?
Oh, yeah, and then from there we could have been rooter.
We didn't say any bad words.
Yeah, see I got you I got you $900.
You're welcome.
Yeah, we each no, it's if I my I was like this is crazy My
job from now on will be just going to all your tournaments.
Going to the tournaments and just...
Wait, this is crazy.
This is so crazy, Doki.
What, like, that is more than people make it a day.
And I got it by watching you.
We have to win.
We have to win to get that.
You can start when lobby is for something.
We gotta start winning.
I want to go to Japan with all of you.
Okay, wait.
All right, next up is melee and abilities only.
So you don't have street fighter abilities, by the way.
You don't, none of us can have guns.
None of us can have guns.
And no grenades.
No grenades.
No guns.
And we just rip it.
There are some characters that are banned.
And they...
So wait, am I allowed to use like my ultimate and stuff like
that?
No, I'm just punching.
Yeah, you are.
You are.
You're allowed to use abilities, like any ability.
any alts just no gun or grenades so if you have an ability
that is a gun then no well it'll be bad it'll be it's it'll
be like bad already so it'll be fine like we don't have to
worry about it um so we'll be fine it's like oh i swear to
you yeah that that i should have had that's the last match i
didn't realize how now i know that i thought it would be
like bad it's okay it was fun that was fun um it it's gonna
be a small map i'm guessing right for us to just be doing
melee like that it's e district it's technically not that
small but like we'll just we'll just run until we'll just
keep running into people don't worry okay no worries but the
next match after that is wild card so so then we start
punching again um i have um i have the the the technically i
mean I should be doing the street fighter characters, right?
Because I was going to say I can do like the healer girl.
But I kind of also want to get the street fighter
characters.
Yeah.
Just play whichever you want is comfortable for you.
I say pick the skin one because it's a skin.
Yeah, I think so too.
I want to say a big thank you for, you know, them putting on
this tournament for us and everything.
Yeah.
I'm giving us free coin.
and we got free coins at yeah at least we got free stuff but
now i know i was like oh there's 10 play like i was like oh
there's 10 teams it should go by really fast like i was
thinking that i didn't realize how long it would take to
like charge up the abilities i i just assumed it would be go
super fast because when i was playing in the match itself it
felt really fast but i don't realize oh playing in a match
that felt fast but other than that this did not feel fast at
all I guess it's different when you're performing, right?
Because you're like stressed out.
But for me, I'm like, la, la, la, la, la.
You have to ready up, yeah.
We're just waiting for the last two players.
We're just waiting for them.
As long as they're ready.
We should be.
I feel like after that, this should go a lot faster now
because it's just play the game.
game wildcard is pretty fast too um there were some really
good fights though for sure the one where like they were
just i felt like there was one fight that lasted forever
when we were watching it but it was so good the last one
yeah that's i was like it's pretty tense i'm gonna get wild
i'll be right back that could be us if we used projectiles
you know what i'm gonna do it i'm a hero if she's not gonna
use projectiles i'm gonna to use projectiles only no no
you're not supposed to don't do it i'm not the one that
everyone deserves i'm the one that they need i am the curse
i am male vtuber i'm the most evil got my water yeah i think
diars must have like water diars must have like quit out of
a war dogs game and went back booted back in It's so funny
that he's like, So did I play a game of War Dog?
How is War Dogs?
Have you guys played it?
No.
I'm...
When the game launched, I spent two hours waiting in queue.
We did not play War Dogs.
Ken Ranny, I run Ken Ranny up.
I just go straight in.
I see all...
Tell them I'm showing up.
I'll tell you, get back in here.
We're readying up.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
I miss clay.
No grenades can heal.
Oh my no guns can.
Oh my god.
He can heal.
Also can shield.
He can shield.
Yeah.
I was like we're not stalling anymore.
I'm excited.
Matara, you said that you're going to play Watson, right?
I can do Watson.
Yeah.
I don't know her.
I don't know her skills.
So I'll take a look.
I have a few.
Why?
Who do you guys want to play?
um no you two pick whatever but then if i'm first pick out
i'll pick gibby okay i think it would be nicer for me to
play like actually the skid characters versus playing the
healing girl i mean we already got third place so we don't
need more money right guys yeah yeah again yeah you got the
money guys also i don't think it's gonna make a big
difference in who i play like i'm not at that skill level
where i'm actually making a difference oh yeah and uh in
game four it's hide and seek and we're gonna be the seekers
so we're gonna be trying to find people let's go wait that
one's fun yeah so we're hunting with the street rider so
we're gonna be hunting people all right tara which one are
you gonna pick can i pick the one you have don't keep or i
could do bangalore as well if i can pick whichever one I'm
going to pick Gibby for end game.
If we live till end game, this would be perfect.
If we do.
Perfect.
What does Gibby do?
He has an alt, which is like a nuke.
So I'll just throw.
Unless there's 20 Watson's, I'm useless.
So let's go.
Okay, let me test my abilities to see how they work.
No grenades, only nukes.
Only nukes.
Oh, that's fine.
We're just, all right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We just roam.
we're just gonna go action mode we're not gonna run away oh
no we kind of should probably get some heals shouldn't yeah
yeah we should yeah all right the only issue is that they
might start oh shit get that gun oh get that made out oh how
do i how do i oh my god i need to get rid of this yeah oh
you tab and right click it tab and right click yeah perfect
thank you oh my god stop i keep accidentally picking them up
okay i need to test out this stuff Yeah, yeah, so just punch
that's it.
That's all I have you just punch and the billies You have
you can put fences in front of you.
So like if they try to punch you um Uh, they try to punch
you they'll have to get through the fences to punch you.
I see I see I see I see I'm like a defensive bunker
character.
Yeah, yeah, I'll scout out.
So what do you guys want to do us strad?
Do you want to just gotta live Just run at them and start
punching them together.
Do you want to be aggressive?
it's better we stick together so like then it'll be like a
three like they're just gonna camp out and find one of us to
punch you know but i mean do you want to be aggressive or do
you want to be a little bit more uh you know what let's be
yeah yeah yeah i want to be aggressive i want action i'm
blood pricey after that no don't worry about me i'm just
scouting for us what does my old do as this character um you
put out a you put out like a pylon and it generates shields
for us and also against you don't want to sit like what if
there's like 20 watson's i'm useless so when i put my alt
down your watson alt will destroy my alt so then if anything
just let me know if we're getting into a fight be like yeah
use old use old use old yeah i'm just praying to god
someone's gonna use crypto and i'm just gonna chuck my alt
down like also grab alt excels if you find any or is oh yeah
the accelerant yeah go to the energy bank and go right in
the center so like if if this happens again where we're like
in the last stat i can just put the little stuff in front of
the door yeah things like that to make it harder yeah yeah
yeah well when when we find someone they're running at us
just start putting fences around you because they have to
punch the fences yeah just grabbing heels for us yep yep yep
yep yep thank you oh my god i'm kind of nervous this is like
i don't know how you guys do tournaments and stuff the
adrenaline is like oh yeah the adrenaline from competitive
guys but this is more so like more uh like not as intense
because oh my gosh i keep grabbing names but there's still
like a certain shaking during that one yeah there's yeah
that's like well like i didn't want to do regular matches
because like i feel like it would be much more um stressful
it well like it'll be like it has to be like fps players
because like then you get beamed down instantly we won't
really hear if they're next to us right because um it's all
uh punches right yeah first blood oh wait wait but they got
two of them but one person is still alive blast is still
alive wait we gotta grab these yellow a lot i would like his
oh oh eliminated oh already yeah yeah remind me so my old
just basically kind of heals us gives the shield yeah so i
use it in fighting basically you know yeah yeah all right
we'll go all the way to see that yellow thing okay actually
let's grab that yellow thing oh my god they went straight in
yeah just follow me just follow me i'm just grabbing a
shield says the more shields we have okay i went the wrong
way i mean i'm i went the wrong way or follow me and we
gotta go all the way to that yellow so we can grab more
shields if i see any like bins because we're all white white
shields right now and the more shields we have the more
advantage you don't want me to grab med kids right your
shields No, no, no, no, you can, I'm talking about these
yellow things.
These yellow things gives us more shields overall, like base
shields.
Yellow thing.
Where I pinged?
So grab shields and health kits.
I'm just grabbing these to increase my base health.
Okay.
Looks like I'm going to talk to you.
I'll take you should know this.
You, you, this has been in, this, these has been in the game
when we played.
They weren't yellow.
What were they?
What color?
Oh, you're just colorblind.
you're in oh are you actually i only see blue ah that's it
take damage i like that all right um let's see where's the
other yellows all right let's go to this one over there we
gotta get evo harvest just follow me we gotta keep an eye
out for this kind of here and yeah we have blue come follow
me this is fun it's just running simulator i like it and
nothing can work for now for now
Yeah, until things start going crazy.
I'm tired.
If anybody is on, you just start putting fences and you'll
be safe.
Okay, yep.
And then we'll come back and help you.
And then it's, I shouldn't ult if anybody's on me.
I should keep that for us.
You shouldn't ult if people are running at you until they
tell you to put it down.
So for now, just, if people start running at you, just start
chucking fences at yourself.
Yeah, just do my cue and just put all the stuff.
Yeah.
some shield batteries oh nice i got a ton too yeah i got
this uh was there another shield none of us have gotten like
the purple armor yet eh uh i don't think we have anything
that can one to upgrade okay we need your controller so you
can oh you're a controller and i'm doing beacon this and
then you can upgrade your armor who's controlling how did
you get up there i think it's isn't aren't can't you do it
this is the planning Or is it Matara?
I don't remember.
I'm not controller.
Who can do this?
Mouse and keyboards.
No, wait, wait, you can do this, Matara.
Come here.
Come with me.
Unless it's Altair.
I don't remember.
I can do it.
Yeah, you can do it.
Altair.
Just do that.
And then we'll give us more armor.
Damn, they started fighting so early.
I'm a surprise.
Oh, I can't get up there.
Hold on.
Oh, little, little.
Doki you gotta slow down What happened what happened?
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
We'll go here Okay, yeah, we're gonna get we're close to
another.
We're close to armor.
We'll go here and then we'll get another armor upgrade Okay,
I think Right what are you gonna do run at us.
Oh, yeah, we're gonna do this or fine nothing to worry about
i got a red beacon for us so actually wait does anyone can
anyone grab this how did you guys see them did you activate
something to see them on the map what altair did scout has
an ability uh you see all these like little stuff around
that can scout for us so you can do the ring council there's
a ring console and you can do that and then it'll show us
where the next different characters do different stuff yeah
yeah is that why So you're a class.
Yeah, you're a class.
So you're class.
So my class is what's going to.
Okay, perfect.
Yeah.
So I think it's I don't know where this is to be fair.
We got a ring.
Yeah, we were literally in between two teams.
It's right here.
Okay, do this Natara.
Yeah.
I'm here.
And you just do this.
Okay.
I just touch it.
Yeah.
Oh, someone's ready to play.
Oh, it's going to show us the next ring and then it's still.
Yep.
Yeah.
And then Altair you can do that.
other one so this means we're like in the oh oh they're
right in front of us okay oh you guys want to zip over here
well that's not rain that's the thing rings over this way
yeah follow me uh i'm following dokey follow me none of
these buildings you can actually camp in so oh i'm scared
i'm scared it's about to happen oh look oh someone's flying
flying on us no it's fine they're not gonna beat us up no
it's fine already got challenges No, they're scared.
They're scared.
Oh, they're trying to scout us.
Oh, oh, oh.
That doesn't do anything.
You're fine.
It's just a tracking.
It doesn't do shit.
You're so fine.
Oh, that was smart.
We should have played Sparrow.
I figured that.
That's actually forgot about Sparrow's.
I actually did unlock him until today.
It was the character I did not do anything with.
I was thinking about playing Bloodhound.
Okay.
I think they're going to the ring console there too.
so we could go there as well.
Come with me.
Should I go up?
Good comms, good comms, good IGL.
Just follow me.
What are you going to do?
Try to fight us?
Oh, they're inside.
They're inside the house.
Okay, again.
Oh, they're trying to get the car.
Okay, do you have a...
Where is this?
Is this up top?
I don't have a zip line yet.
Yeah.
The zip all the way up here.
I see we moved this way.
Are they challenges?
They'll challenge us.
It's fine.
I'm doing it.
Hold on, look at them.
They're scared.
Oh, they're like, yeah, you're like, yeah, yeah.
Come on, let me pull you.
All right, wait, wait, do this.
Do this.
I'll guard you.
Should I do it?
Oh, wait, there's so many people here.
All right, let's leave now.
Let's add shield.
Holy crap.
Let's leave.
I just wanted to do that.
This is not ring anyway.
I wanted to get shields.
Scary.
All right, now we just chill.
Heart is beating.
They are following us.
Are you actually following?
No, they're not.
Yes.
They jump.
One of them jumped down.
Oh, yeah.
He's still my beating heart.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I see what you see.
Oh, there's two teams.
There's two teams.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I wasn't.
Yeah.
Come on.
What if I pull one towards me?
Oh, yeah.
It's trying to see you grab.
Oh, they're running away.
Oh, there's a bunch of teams.
just one this just one okay tell me one's a good time for my
not yet not yet everybody all they're tracking it's fine i
don't know how to get up this wall actually oh i can't hold
space yeah hold it yeah we're just intimidating them to a
certain extent they're they don't want to challenge this
they're fucking pussies right now they're coming no they're
not there's a They were trying to...
Come here.
Come here with me.
That takes damage.
I'm sorry.
Just come here.
Oh, yeah.
It's okay.
Oh, if they try to push up, they'll run away because just
heal.
I'll guard you.
Yeah.
I'm a tour.
I think your shield ought to regenerate.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
You don't have to.
You don't have to shield.
Yeah.
Okay.
You just wait.
So you saw that red thing.
So I forgot about Sparrow's ability.
So we're a little fucked when there's going to be 20 of that
at end game.
So I forgot that guy existed.
Okay.
forgot he was the last character to show up so maybe i can
just do a zipline going straight up at the last circle to
safety that's so true wait i i have a redeploy we can use
this uh just yeah yeah we can go up it there's a lot of
teams left there's only one team that got eliminated so yeah
i know i was i'm surprised i don't i don't know what should
we rat or what oh my god by game oh my god oh my god that
lagged me so hard but it was Yeah, I saw, I was wondering
what was going on.
I thought I, okay, we're going to grab this for shield.
I was like, hopefully shit is like hacker mode.
I'm in.
How do you grab it?
Do you just say it?
It's on top.
Don't, don't, don't, don't, don't get out of here.
Okay, it can squash you.
It can switch.
That was close.
It almost.
Okay, nothing.
I literally almost died.
Yeah, yeah, you could have gotten squashed, but that's how I
almost died in the creator tournament.
That would have been so funny.
legit it actually would have uh oh they got me am i okay oh
they got me do you want to do any kind of strat when like we
get attacked do we just kind of all we do is okay so the
strat is you put down we get attached just put fences down
that's literally the strat you just grab because they have
to get through your fences to kill us all right so
apparently you probably just gang up on one person shouldn't
yeah we just all focus on it's gonna be tough because
everyone's together Oh shit.
They got no, they got here people people wait wait wait wait
Yep, come to me.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I thought that that that oh my god.
They got glurm glopp.
They got here Glurm glopp
There's somebody running on the side here.
There's a team on the side there.
I'm going to deeper in zone Okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I said no, I know where oh, yeah, can we
even be up top there?
I don't know.
I mean try ready to fly i didn't get any alt excel so like
that's the thing i'm worried about nope nope nope okay we
can use it to get across back up work back down yeah oh yeah
i'm all excited and get any oh this is gonna get rough
there's nine okay all right so um you can make a okay
they're behind us behind us behind us okay so make a fence
here okay matara put a fence here press q right sorry i'm
like here and then put another queue here connect that and
then connect as long as you can you don't have to yeah and
then there you go yeah so they have to get up okay here do
it how long is it gonna go for um come over here put a new
one uh-huh put what in here let's go oh i'm out of hold on
oh yeah recharging it just recharge it i don't know how many
fences you can put you guys want to come up they're watching
okay they're they're like out of the way yeah they come with
next circle goes first yeah all right and then I gotta yeah
so it's like I just found these like forever no uh no
there's a limit I think that's the last one you can do okay
yeah uh you can make as long as you can and then we'll have
like this is our wall like a toll we're still in the zone
yeah put a zipline to us right already inside the ring it's
the line here this little guy right yeah yeah okay make it
as directly up as possible so anyway this is the steepest I
can make it nice all right so we go up And then, okay.
I don't know.
Okay, wait.
Are they definitely still at the zone or are they outside of
the zone now?
All right, come here.
Come here.
Okay.
I'm surprised nobody played crypto.
I assume.
Okay, while you fix that, I'm going to fix myself real
quick.
I'm never getting.
there i believe okay you got jumped midway or like almost
midway that's all you gotta do yeah oh oh they're coming
they're coming no they're not no they're we're so fine
they're not gonna come up there's no way see they're they're
they're too scared see we have our little toll we have a
little toll so they can't get in here jump on some of that
wait who died there's eight squads left which team died how
do we jump on them how do we kill them oh it just it's okay
you just come safe here we have okay we don't know matai
matai you're safe you're very sick matai do not worry I have
another Hotel we have the high ground.
We have the high ground.
We have the high ground now.
What are they gonna do?
What are they?
Why did no one play crypto?
I went all in hoping someone would play crypto.
But everyone was hoping the other person would play crypto.
So I'm sorry, what crypto does is that when he alts, he
eliminates all the fences and all of this.
So we're gonna be in hell.
there's one minute left nobody for my old i forget no not
yet not yet so um we're it's gonna be a little bit of an
issue because um nobody decided to play crypto because
everyone assumed that someone would play crypto uh fellas
i'm gonna do this so we can zip line back and forth above oh
my god that's so smart that's no don't worry don't worry
just no we can't we can't zip Double jump twice on up there.
This is not you can't when do they change that?
What do you mean?
You can only stand there twice.
Oh my god.
Look at this little ring.
They have here
I'm so stressed.
We're gonna we're gonna we're gonna be fine with that.
We're gonna do fine
We're fine.
It pushed me up!
Don't worry.
We have...
It pushed me up.
I can't explain it.
Just stay here.
Don't worry.
Someone has a Watson ult, so we're fine.
Someone has a Watson ult, so we're okay.
I have...
You don't have to ult, Matari.
Someone else is gonna...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There's 20 other Watson ults going on.
How do I keep falling?
I'm not moving and it's like falling.
Yeah, some it was impact.
Oh, this is bad.
There's the Nobody played crypto.
Nobody played crypto.
This is so bad I had the most stressful thing I've
experienced in like the last few months y'all Okay, but
technically you want okay, I'm sorry.
Do you want to be even more stressed?
No
I Take those items out of there.
Pressy pressy pressy pressy pressy Okay, I'm zipping I'm
zipping Oh my god, get out of me get out of me Ah Traitor I
might have This is the room for our team I'm sorry
I I might have got out I have no idea what I'm doing I have
no idea what I'm doing I'm like, it's locked out Stay alive.
Stay alive.
Yeah, I really am.
Oh, shit.
I really am.
I'm fucking, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I have to be honest with you, I don't understand anything.
I self-sabotaged our own team for fun.
I don't know what happened.
Okay, so I punched Altair off the high ground and that's...
cost him I lost half my HP and then he lost half his HP and
then um Joki Bird what about the money for our okay to be
fair I thought it would be really funny and and it was
really funny it was really funny honestly if it's for the
bit it was it was for the bit guys it was all terrible
remember this yeah and then but then the thing is we will
win the next one you know we'll win the night i want to be
honest with you guys the amount of adrenaline i felt seeing
like 20 players around me in a small space oh my god it was
electric it was really you should watch fortnite games there
was like 60 people in the last circle oh yeah yeah yeah and
then there's like houses are being built and it was really
fun to wrap though yeah see it was okay but the end game i
did my it may be trolled up a little bit maybe just a little
ewe eighth place it's okay that's okay we have other we can
we can make it back in the other games we already got third
you know we already got third we don't we sure we sure
earned our third spot from the previous game we sure did you
hey i asked if you want to feel a little bit more stressed I
did But I said no No I was She said no And you should have
answered it a little bit faster Not really I'm having such a
fun That like that was so stressful in a fun way Alright let
me Let me stop streaming To show them A new New lobby Oh my
god I'm like I actually feel like I just worked out I'm like
Oh all right game three is wild card again okay awesome
that's true fiber you can beat people up again you can beat
people up that's what i want oh wait a second i accidentally
closed my game give me one second okay tell them i'm
constipated now no they're gonna wait i'm done with my
diarrhea all right ready ready when everyone in i'm gonna
make it we're gonna try and go fast because there's three
more games and then yeah i'm going i'm going i'm logging in
i'm literally oh i went through a lot yeah i woke her up i
woke her i actually feel like i did a workout just now that
was electric i'm so not used to this and like these
stressful situations so for me it's like wow i love it
exactly no i how often do you get to do something for the
first time as an old hag you know, never.
That's true.
I've never been an old hag.
I don't know.
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
I'm 21.
Season 5.
I'll never age.
And I'll never age.
Tick tock.
You should have known she was going to punch you after she
punched me.
You should have known she was going to like re-re, you know.
I already accepted the truth.
One out of two.
You played with her before.
You know her games you played these games before so i know
it's inevitable even if i move out of the way she'll move
herself this is what you get for being a bystander elter if
you stuck up for matara then you wouldn't have gotten you
wouldn't gotten bullied too you know so somehow this loops
back to my all my it's all the bystander you let matara get
beat up and in turn it was karma um technically criminal who
beat them up technically i never got beat up technically uh
i did beat you out of the high ground so
so you don't get to use any weapons or grenades or any
damaging legend act tactical ultimate abilities well i mean
i get to do street fighter stuff though i is street fighter
we're gonna be sniping this round okay okay so this round
it's the same as the warm-up round all abilities all punches
you know everything goes for us are any other damaging
legend tactic oh i didn't make that rule i that what they
made i didn't know that surprise they wanted to surprise
they thought you were too powerful oh wait but my my
abilities aren't damaging i'm on luke luke doesn't damage he
just disappears which team one last time was it that Team
perfect.
I don't know which team won actually.
It was so key.
I didn't actually did not look at the bracket to see who won
It went by so fast Was a team perfect?
It doesn't say the brackets doesn't say who won that one.
So I actually don't know does anyone know?
I actually the one time I forgot to look at the bracket
Looks like heavenly needs to pee or Give me a sec Hey, no,
no, no, boy, yes, yes, no, no, when you can just punch me
off the ledge, no, tie himself up.
Or just missing three more.
You know what, what, maybe what I need to pursue is like
professional esports, because the adrenaline that I feel
like I feel so exhilarated right.
Yeah, yeah, maybe this is what I needed in my old years.
years well luckily I'm not used to this level of adrenaline
to keep you on track oh to keep you like uh on track you
know so you don't get dementia yeah like I actually feel
like wow I just like I feel drunk but I didn't drink that's
good you know keeps you young I just you guys have to
realize I don't pull myself in high pressure situations ever
well you know how to take a punch maybe you don't need wine
anymore you just gotta play apex tournaments you guys gotta
play tournaments oh all right we're gonna start now by
tournaments and suffer it's wild card time let's go god isa
okay we're gonna be hunting them down during the next map
game mode after this one right yeah after this after this so
okay this is what we're going to play after this.
We're going to play, because they can't alt this time.
So we're in the clear.
So we're going to be playing Gippy, Caustic, and Bangalore.
And all we do in the final ring, I'll be Caustic.
All we do in the final ring, if it's not the final ring, we
just alt.
And then...
I thought...
Oh, because they're not supposed to use their alts, right?
Because they can't do anything.
So all they can do, and then we grab a bunch of Names.
Okay.
Wait, where am I going to play?
I only have Bangalore unlocked.
Well, not this one.
This one you play wherever fuck you want.
This is the melee one.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Is it?
Yeah, this is the wild card melee.
Yeah, this is the same one as we did at the beginning.
We're making like punch, but we can also shoot.
My favorite ship is friendship.
And I'll do the skins ones because it's pretty.
Oh, my God.
I'm like coming off of...
I'm coming down.
I might need a coffee after this.
to get back up.
Easy first place is coming.
It's so crazy because I know from the VOD it's literally
just I'm running after you guys but I the whole time was
scared that there's going to be a team coming up on us for
some reason.
So I was in like high alert adrenaline the whole time.
You're like paranoid as hell.
That's good though.
That's good.
It's so funny.
All right.
I'll take us you know what i'll take us i'll take us here
perfect and then should be fine there's a lot of coin trucks
here okay we can still use guns in this one right yes you
guys can use guns i i just need remember not to have a gun
everything goes for you guys i just i can just make it i
keep freaking
used to get at the game used to get at the game all right
we're five i don't have damaging abilities i have fire
breaching charge what is that oh oh you're trying out oh it
breaks doors so you can use it oh apparently i can't pick up
names if anyone wants the coin truck it's right here.
There's a coin truck.
I got the heirloom.
Yeah, guys.
It's one of the first heirloom I've ever bought.
Yeah.
What's an heirloom?
It's like the special weapons.
You know, like CSGO knives is basically like that.
Sudden jump scares and adrenaline rushes can land me in the
ICU.
Yeah.
Well, okay, wait.
So I just gotta punch the truck.
Yeah, punch the truck and you get your full abilities.
Yeah.
Yeah, and then it'll level it all up.
Nice.
Yeah.
I need a backpack.
Yeah, watch this, guys.
Oh.
I'm about to end this man's whole career.
What are we watching?
Okay, do you guys want me to lock?
Do you guys want me to give you guys a 2v3 or you guys want
me to contribute in the fight?
I would love to win a little bit of money.
I'm not gonna lie.
Listen, but we did win a little bit of money.
I didn't want to be the one to say it.
But we did win a little bit of money.
So you won't win.
You don't you won't win lots of money.
Is that what you're trying?
I love to win a lot more money Yes.
And you know the best part is I am not entitled to any of it
because I am by far the least, you know, good person.
But you're here.
You can win what I want.
Charity.
No.
All right.
Then let's walk around then.
I mean, let's walk around till we find someone.
You guys all kit it up?
Sure.
All right.
We'll go this way.
Well, now that I know you guys want to win lots of money.
She's going to troll us, isn't she?
She's going to troll us.
People, people, people, people.
Why are you scared?
Oh, okay.
King them.
Oh, they're miraging.
Oh, wait.
They're all fake.
These ones?
These are real.
Oh, these guys are real.
I cracked one.
Oh, these are real.
They're real.
Ah!
Sorry.
I thought I...
Where are they?
Wait, they're over here.
Oh, they're...
What's up?
Behind us?
Punch it!
Punch him!
Oh, that was you.
Sorry.
Alright, well, I'm not wasting my ability.
I'm backing up.
Oh, that got wasted my ability.
It's fine.
Yeah, they're fully run out.
You want to go get the coin truck?
I mean, reset my ability.
I'm over here.
Oh, yeah, they...
Oh, wait.
There's more.
There's another team here.
Oh, they're playing.
You got a sniper behind us.
All right, come with me.
I'm fine.
I know they're not going to shoot me.
I know they're...
I'm following you, Doki.
I'm following you, Doki?
I feel their aura and they have none.
I feel their aura.
Their run is crazy!
They got no aura.
They're riseless.
Don't keep it disrespected.
All right, I'm good.
All right, so what they're doing, they're playing ring.
They're playing final ring.
They don't want to fight.
So, all right, follow me.
Let's ruin their dreams and hopes.
All right, let's follow me.
Oh, they want to keep, you don't want to brawl yet.
The thing is, as long as one of us is alive, we should be
good.
All right, just follow.
Oh, Altair, where are you?
Altair, we're not there.
Yeah, but I'm having fun.
Oh, that's true.
Behind us?
Now he's sniping.
He's just poking at them.
He's being a little silly goofy.
I'm with me.
I'm here behind you.
I'm ready to punch as soon as we can punch here.
Oh.
I'm here.
Oh, punch me.
Oh, my alt is not.
Oh my god.
It's not ready.
I didn't realize it's fine.
You're you're you're okay.
One down.
Yeah, yeah, I'm okay.
Nice.
Where are they?
I'll come back up in a second.
Do you guys need me to hold?
We are already inside the ring.
Oh, she's right here.
Yeah, sorry.
I thought I pressed alt, but it didn't activate, so I
panicked.
He ran, he ran.
I'm he, I'm he.
Oh, one is right there.
Yeah.
One, one, one, one, one.
Oh, oh!
I got what?
Oh, sorry.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's fine.
You're so healthy.
Where's the other one?
All right.
Now I got my one as you.
You guys is turning to get the others.
Oh, that's you.
Wait, leave one of them alive.
Leave one of them alive.
Leave the one of them.
No.
Leave one of them.
Come on.
Leave one of them alive.
No.
Leave her alive.
Play with your food a little bit, guys.
Behind us, behind us, behind us, up top.
Behind us, behind us, up top.
all right i'm here oh something somebody's hitting me from
up there i got he's cracked oh no i got sonar oh okay wait
okay guys i don't have any more juice so i got sonar i got
sonar i can't wait wait no no no i don't have anybody's
right here i don't have any more fighting juice so i'm left
okay oh no guys i literally i'm leaving he's coming up it's
all right it's all right i just need juice i just don't have
any No!
Up here!
Finishing me!
Okay, I played with my food a little too much.
Oh no, the finisher.
It's okay, Matara's coming back.
Stay alive, stay alive.
I'll stay alive.
Don't worry.
Matara's back.
Don't worry, yes.
Yeah.
I might have played away.
Right.
Yeah.
I might have played with my food a little too much.
Now I ran out of, I don't have juice anymore.
So I'm food.
She played with me.
Hey, what?
Okay, that's we just for.
Oh, people, people.
Right here.
You guys have to shoot them.
All I can do is.
Oh, that was right.
They're closed.
So they don't.
Oh, I don't know where you are.
Oh, I can't do anything about it.
I don't have juice, guys.
They're all clones.
I don't have juice.
This one's real.
Okay Nice it All right, I can't do anything for you guys.
I really am just being not holding so just let me know
whenever I should hold Oh, whenever you can all here you can
all here now we want you know It's all right if they come at
us again, Regis, I'm gonna hold Okay, I mean all right now
doesn't really matter.
It gives Yeah, yeah But it doesn't last long, right?
It's forever.
Wait.
Alt here.
Alt here and put fences.
Oh, my dog is angry.
All right.
So I'm useless right now.
I'm practiced.
Why?
Because I have no juice.
I have no juice.
So we get the juice back.
I need a grab.
Somebody shooting me?
Hey.
No.
How many shooting me from up here?
All right.
I'm marked by vantage.
Yeah, let's not.
Let's not fight that.
Don't worry.
You put fences start putting fences around us.
All right, I'm gonna try and find juice.
Give me a sec Is that how he quick revert works that like if
you don't have coins you um, it's street fighter thing So
it's like I can't do anything if I don't have any uh I need
to grab like actual Coins so I'm farming coins right now.
We can pass by our okay.
Yeah, it is fine You guys don't have to worry about me.
I will so I can run away if I need to
So the old just doesn't disappear it just stays like wow
okay yeah they're up here fighting they're fighting another
team up there all right oh my god i'm actually dead come do
me come into me come into me come into me okay okay wait
where are you we're coming i'm over i'm here i'm leading
them here i'm leading this to us they're here they're here
one hp one hp one hp all right stay in there stay in there
that's tired
We're toxic, Doki!
We're toxic!
Oh no!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
I'm picking you up on my body right now!
It was deserved!
Hey!
No!
Okay.
I baited him!
What did you do?
I have no idea.
And then I ran, but I used to get back and I baited him into
our pit of death.
Oh, everything rolled.
Yeah.
I mean, this is like the most baby, baby's first wall, as
you can see.
I literally baited the man into the pit and I'll do it
again.
I had nothing too.
That's the thing.
I didn't have anything so.
Oh, Toki, there's somebody like right there.
No, I'm here.
Don't worry.
I'm right here.
We're good.
Oh, someone's running across the field behind us.
I'm coming.
I'm going back.
On that rock.
Oh, whoa.
I can see the shield generator.
I'm just...
hang out last second i'm hanging out the thing is i do need
more juice
all right let's see all right there's also like people there
wait all right i got i'm gonna say i see what you mean about
the shield generator but there's also people yeah okay let's
try to tell my dog not to park it wait okay they're also
yeah they're like all around no he just wants food but he's
not feeding time yet we're fine don't want worry nothing to
worry about can i recast my old technically or do i just yes
you can recast it okay all right oh
thank you there's so much to like focus on in this game this
you guys are fine you guys are totally fine yeah they're
coming from here there's like oh they're coming they're
they're coming in they're coming in they're trying to kidnap
you so be careful i'm just kidnap yeah so they are doing a
portal where oh that guy oh yeah we got sonar so they know
where we are it's it's fine everybody knows where we are as
long as i don't go into this pit we're fine this is like the
pit of death oh i'm just playing around right now don't
worry when When the time comes, I'll lock in for us.
Yeah, there's a bunch of them just chilling here.
I'm just fucking around.
Don't worry, I won't.
I won't die.
Trust me.
I'll be fine.
Yeah, they're fighting.
They're fighting.
Wait, which way?
On the side?
Yeah, middle mouse button.
Don't go, don't go, because they're like all here.
Middle mouse button in this ping.
Yeah, see they're fighting here.
They're fighting here.
Whoa.
Hey, guys.
I'm here.
I mean, it was like very, very.
This is the most...
This is the most turtled...
Everybody's so...
I don't have any grenades for that.
Oh, you teleported to the right.
It's fine.
If you want to come to me, we can set up a new area.
Oh.
What?
Come to me if you want to set up somewhere new.
Do we... Because my...
Alright, you can stay here.
I mean, you can stay here.
It's fine.
They're walking in, walking in, walking in.
One cracked out there.
On me, I'm on the rock.
Get him, get him.
Just beat him.
Just keep beating him.
Keep beating him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Beat him.
Okay, where's the other ones?
They're coming in here.
I see the other ones.
Yeah, keep beating him up.
Rock is cracked really low.
One close to us.
I have to shield.
Just beat him up.
Beat him up.
Yeah, I don't see them.
Oh, it's fine.
Then we did it.
Oh, there's two here.
Okay, there's three here.
I'm coming back.
We're fine.
Oh, it's about to be final.
I'm charged up.
I'm charged up now.
We're so healthy.
I'm so, that actually charged me up.
They're here.
They're all here.
It's fine.
We're fine for now.
Oh, heal up.
Heal up.
And then you have your ult, right?
I just used my ult.
It's right here.
That's fine.
Just wait a little bit.
Okay.
We got, I'll tear it.
The zone's coming.
So we got to slowly.
All right.
So there's people above us.
So.
Okay.
Push up.
People on the side people on the side.
Oh,
oh my god, I actually got hit.
Just keep beating me up.
No, I got him.
Oh, no.
He died.
I got that.
Okay, it's fine.
No!
We got four.
I accidentally hit him.
But I smell the gun.
We got fourth.
It's fine.
We killed a guy, right?
Oh, he is so first.
We got second.
Oh, my sure.
Yeah, that was an all-out Broadway.
Who got first?
We got fourth, not first.
We got no, but who got fourth, though?
Who got first, though?
Oh, heavenly.
There's some cool skins.
Yeah, that was close.
Oh, my.
That was so stressful.
But like a good, I don't think you, I don't think, I think
the three of us had like very different experiences with
what just happened.
I was fucking around till the end.
I, hey, I got it till the end.
My POV, I was just glued to the wall and I was scared, but I
had fun.
And at the end, I know I did some damage, so that's
important.
Yeah, as long as...
I got 10 kills.
Oh my God, 20 kills.
swag champion that's insane who wait you got 20 kills um the
fun the team that got first heavenly oh my god
all right that was really fun that was really fun now all
right so for us we three we can do whatever we are gonna do
gibraltar caustic yep and i was thinking about sparrow but
it just slows people down.
So I don't think it really doesn't really matter unless you
want to do Sparrow.
I think Sparrow's recon.
I actually don't do Sparrow.
Where you Sparrow's recon.
I know we didn't ban him, but I mean, it's a little
cheating.
So I think we should do Bangalore, Cossack, and Gibby.
And we play for end game, basically.
Bangalore, Cossack, Gibby.
Yeah, I'll go Cossack.
Our game here, this is the one where we seek people or is it
another round?
Yeah, we kill people.
If you see someone, just shoot them.
And Tara, if you want, you can come with me and shoot
people.
All right, so what I do usually, I would like fuck with
people and I won't run around with my gun and I'll just like
run around with people and then make them think I'm a hider
and then I'll shoot them later.
Oh, that's funny.
So we both run together and we both run together.
People won't know that, people won't know that we're the
hunters because they'll think we're both hiders because
usually what they think is that the hunters would be split
up to hunt as many people as they want.
yeah but then the hiders oh you're so so if we both go
together and then i'll tell you just go do other you want
you just go in nuclear mode so matara and i we're gonna play
mind games even come with us if you want that would be three
hiders just sticking together you guys do whatever girls do
kooties are gross well i mean i'll tell you i mean i'll tell
you you want to come with us we'll just rock it together
yeah so i want to go by myself i want i want to i want We
are getting lots of kill.
Oh, man.
All right.
You go split up Matara now.
We're going to hold hands and we're going to trick some
people.
Yeah, we're going to trick some people and bait them to us.
I love tricking people.
See, the righteous thing to do would just be to kill them.
But you trick them and then kill them.
That's evil.
We're marinating them, you know, being thinking, well, okay,
here's the planetarium.
We're going to invite one.
We're going to have one person running with us.
We're going to, they'll think we're best friends.
We're going to crouch next to them in the corner.
Yeah, they're going to be like, hey, guys, we're just
chilling.
We're just chilling.
So should I currently get some guns or no?
No, you'll get guns.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
They won't know.
So like a lot they won't be observant enough to see us
having guns.
So what do they know what skin I'm using?
I'm kidding.
I'm switching to Bangalore anyway, right?
So they won't know.
No, no, no.
Cost it.
I mean, if they're smart, they will realize that maybe, you
know, It's a little weird that there's a hide that's a
caustic, but like, they won't know.
They won't know.
So, Doki, do you know if there's a list of all the
participants anywhere?
Um, I can give you, I can send it to you.
Um, let's see.
My cute cat wants belly rubs.
I'm giving.
Oh, rubber, rub her belly.
Rub my belly.
No, you don't deserve belly rubs.
Rub her belly.
After this, I'll feed you.
And Makara, if we win big, I'll feed you tuna.
I'll feed you.
Hey, if Doki wins.
Matara, Matara, Matara is hoping for herself.
Real.
Hello?
I think Doki crashed.
Yeah, I crashed.
What the fuck?
I got fatal error.
I- Wait, my apex crashed.
Are you cheating?
oh no i don't know give me a sec my apex holy crap i've
never i had a weird bug that i've never had before i was
like what the is that give me like a weird error code i've
never seen that error code before but we're back i'm petting
my cat anything like i said anything that could go wrong
will go wrong for me i'm just i'm just it's it's it's it's
okay as this get it it's the day we toughen it out you're
doing great i would never be able to do one of these you're
crazy oh i yeah under a week yeah under a week was a little
ambitious just a little bit all right i need to get the code
again i mean if heavenly it was uh erb right okay grabbing
his food outside all right now i gave me an error code
specifically for apex so i was just like what the fuck i
like oh is that not the code i'm not i kept going back in oh
there you go i'm in all right now i'm um i'll just say i'm r
now i'm r oh oh wait wait matara's matara no it She's a
seeker.
It's okay.
I'm just checking.
I'm still making my coffee, but Heavenly, I think, is still
AFK.
Oh, is he?
Okay.
Joki, I'm having...
Oh, he's back.
Okay, perfect.
I'm having so much fun.
Oh, I'm glad.
I'm glad you're having fun.
That's all I wanted.
Honestly, like...
Wow.
This is a little bit above my pay grade, though, for,
like...
But I'm having so much fun.
I'm glad.
That's all I want.
be fun as long as you're having fun um that's all i want for
you guys all right he's back we're all back let's run it
i'll grab my coffee after this round yeah oh all right here
we go i'm ready all right so all they're all you're gonna do
they're just gonna all right matara and i will just stay
together uh where wait what are you guys gonna play i play
caustic who's playing Bangalore.
I'll play the Bangalore.
Alright, so I'll tear you.
I don't know if I have Gibby, so I'll try Gibby.
Alright.
We're supposed to be good.
I definitely don't have Gibby if that's... Oh, I'm sorry.
I think you have Gibby.
She broke there.
Let's hear.
I don't remember if it was
like...
Is that the big guy with the shield?
Yeah, that's a Kuma.
It's a Kuma.
I don't...
Oh, I don't have a skin.
Oh, no!
Oh, if you don't have the skin, I guess like, yeah, it's
okay.
I'm Blanca.
People will be like, oh, she's just on Blanca to show off
the skin, you know?
Oh, and then you're Bangalore and Matata.
Remember to click it?
Yeah, click it.
Oh, Bangalore?
Oh, wait.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wow.
So what are her abilities?
Let me see.
In a moment.
Her Q is a smoke.
And her alt.
Okay, don't, you don't, we don't, you don't have the alt
until the final ring.
Yeah, until we like get there.
Yeah, I'll tell you the alt and just throw it in the middle.
Okay, they don't know which one is.
Do you want us to start attacking them before the final
ring?
No, no, no, you can attack, but we're just gonna...
The first person we see...
Alright, come with me, Matara.
We're gonna land.
We're gonna land here.
And then I'm gonna...
Just go wherever the fuck you want us to kind of...
Actually, I'm gonna take us all the way to the back just to
make it more fair for people to just run around doing stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I'm just gonna...
We're just gonna stall a little bit, make it more fair for
everybody.
So we're just gonna...
as i can we got fourth and we got third you guys is that
enough money are you guys happy are you guys happy well yeah
do you guys it's been really really fun honestly my my my
reward has been like the the the fish comment has been my
reward that has been absolutely i also okay amatara grab as
many uh you don't we don't really need shields so grab as
many names ammo and ultimate excels if you find them okay so
you just we don't need healing technically right we don't
we're just shooting they can't do anything back to us i
instantly ran into people i'm letting them live yeah let
them live just just i don't say the beginning like run run
run with them you know run with them i'm just sending some
you know friendly shots if you're no no you should run with
them they won't run with them out there just just run come
on you know you want So you know, you just know, I don't
want to kill him.
I want to eat their soul over.
Later, just play with your food a little bit.
You know, she is big on that.
Shut up and eat your food.
She is huge on that.
She's evil.
Play with your food a little.
I'm grabbing a linga.
It's not too bad.
Recharge mode.
Interesting.
Oh, that just breaks doors.
Remember to grab backpacks when you can too.
I want to see in the backpack here.
do do come on live a little of terry been fun to watch i'm
happy i'm using a wingman i'm living life right now oh okay
that's maybe a living life too hard i'm crazy and grab as
many names and ammo as you can oh yeah as many made an ammo
you said yeah and for your gun whatever gun you're using all
right it's time it's seeking time I'm not put okay and also
make sure your gun is in here isn't showing so that they see
you running with the gun right yeah I'm gonna start hunting
I'm already widowmaker I'm Gibraltar hey, oh, I'm Oh, I'm
doing this little oh, wait have you guys already started
running yeah to the purple?
Yeah, okay.
I'm following.
I'm not even wasting my time.
Hey guys I'm totally not even wasting.
Wait, how did you even get there?
Oh my goodness.
You guys, Matara, you should come over to me.
Oh yeah, I should.
You should.
I should.
There's guys there and we're hiding.
I just want...
We're hiding, we're hiding, we're hiding.
Hello?
Anybody here?
We're making friends.
We're making friends, although they're going to hear a shoot
when I come closer.
Well, I will wait till I'm like right there.
I'm going.
He said hi!
Oh, that's cute.
We're making friends.
When I come in, I'm going to like teabag and pretend I'm
like chilling, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
Just hang out with us.
You found people?
Yeah, I found.
Yeah, I did.
Nice.
Treasure them, okay?
Treasure the moment that you had before you came.
We're gonna be best friends.
We're gonna be...
That's what I'm scared of.
Best friends.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Oh my god.
It's come to me.
I'm your friend.
You are?
Oh, yeah.
You also found a friend?
Yeah.
adopt this guy i'm gonna call them dulcine who's this guy
who is this person but technically they could respawn if we
don't eliminate all of them right i'll be here i'll be in
this corner a little puffy my matara you ready wait wait i'm
let me let me also like uh do my little crouch just crouch
just and then just start crouching at us
Sorry, dude.
Oh, SK, I'm so sorry.
Oh, no, I'm not gonna...
I gotta do it.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I feel bad.
Okay, Matara, are you ready to end his misery?
Okay, I'll do a countdown.
Three, two.
Oh, sorry, buddy.
Sorry, buddy.
sorry we're assassinating people now it felt great i'm so
sorry i i apologize that felt so cruel that felt so cruel
but i had to do with you fidel i'm so sorry i i people are
hiding well yeah as the circle gets smaller right really i
know he's gonna tell your friends tell your friends It's
Bangalore and Caustic Don't use the Bangalore and the
Caustic Beware of the Caustic
Beware Oh I should have let him live To be fair they can
craft them back But I don't know if they know that That's
the only issue I just feel so bad for doing that man I'll
get over it feel a little bit cruel i'm not gonna lie don't
get over it you've already gotten over it yeah she's already
gotten over fidel who if it was anyone else all right now
i'll kill i'll kill one or two you know what i haven't i've
only found that one person that dokey found i haven't found
anybody else oh i found several other people but i was just
really how yeah because you're hiding she smells the blood
you're not hiding oh wait why don't we pick recon characters
oh you're not allowed to we're not allowed to oh okay that's
smart i think this to be really easy if we just had like a
blood help i mean it would be fair it won't be yeah it won't
be fair poor for people have been here Ooh, put some gas
cans.
Anyone crossing my toes.
Oh, I like how our plan was to like get together.
And then we just started.
The moment I killed, we're like one and done.
The moment we killed Fidel.
One and done.
We're like, it's over.
The band's breaking up.
Friendship is over.
We're coming back.
Girls, we grow together.
No, the band's breaking up.
You're too good.
You run so fast.
What do you mean?
I've been at the same speed.
Oh, where are you?
Where are you?
I don't know.
I found one.
Get up close to them.
Don't shoot them.
I want to walk.
And then there's one.
There's one.
Oh, I'll head over there.
Yeah, head over.
Yeah, I'll cross over.
Oh I'm handing over yeah, someone's getting rest are you Oh,
okay Eski or Fidel are you baiting them?
Ah, I'm thinking them for you.
Oh, are you?
Are you right?
Are you shooting them or are they just running from you?
No, no, no, they're just running from me They're like spread
the word They know they know Bangalore ain't got spread they
know They know No, I should have just attacked.
I guess they're coming into the big hide.
Are they coming to the tunnels?
I lost them.
They're not.
No, they're not there.
Where are these guys?
I'm in the tunnels now.
And she's in the tunnels.
I'm in the tunnels.
Maybe I should hide near the corners of the map.
I don't see them.
They definitely are not in the tunnels.
The guy like ran away from me.
He was running.
I don't know how we were running the same speed, but he ran.
slide, jump, you run faster.
Or like you do more distance.
Well, the circle is closing.
Oh, you can hear it.
Oh, two res is then.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
All right.
Hey, I found someone's jump pad.
I'm looking around the court.
I'm going to hug the edge of the ring.
Usually hiders, what they do is just hide the edge.
Go to the edge of the ring.
The edge of the ring.
There's a ring.
Oh, they know they let's spread the word.
I'm telling you, I think they instantly were like, all
right, it's this character.
So that's why now they like they know or they're why.
OK, wait, am I going to get stuck in the ring?
Oh, wait, wait.
Where are you?
No, you're oh, oh, go here.
Go here.
Matara, Matara.
Look at him.
Go here.
Look where I'm paying.
Just follow my ping.
You have heels or no?
Yes.
Okay.
Just go here and I'll tell you.
Actually, we can resair.
I'll resair.
but that's it it's okay if you if you die and ring i'll res
you will res okay this is actually really funny it's because
i was following that guy no why did you go back where are
these people they're very good hi there's not gonna lie i am
going to die by the way just die just die just die and ring
and i'll craft you wait i'll tell you do you have a res near
you or no okay I have a red near me.
I have a red.
I do have a red.
Oh, no.
No, no.
It's upside down.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll wait for Amatara to die.
All right.
I got you.
I'm a crazy rabbit squirrel and I want some cookies.
Let me kill you.
All right.
Wow.
I'm respawning.
Respawning.
All right.
How lame.
I'm going to check these corners to see if anybody's...
chillin I found someone you did yeah yeah did you see
anybody while you were in the air no and I dropped like
instantly cuz I was oh there's a guy next to me oh I see him
shoot him shoot him shoot you have to shoot this guy he
knows he knows he knows the guy that was running for me he
knows and he's got so sorry doing work I'm so sorry oh man I
don't think I can get him he's already like way too far away
from me yeah he's so far psychopath lobby hide and seek yeah
they're actually like you fall into the lava yeah you fell
in the lava didn't you you fell in the lava didn't you all
right would i throw my oh do not throw any thermal grenades
okay do everything they're only thermal grenades fuck my own
up does thermal explode everything i think thermal fucks my
own up oh man that guy was so fast i think that's the guy
that ran away from me the first time but nobody trusts each
other oh what happened why is this guy hiding i need that or
no are you hiding all your oh that's cute LT that's cute oh
I'm sorry punch kid I'm sorry I feel really bad like I I
genuinely it's not fun I feel cool but we're like nobody is
safe innocence in her eyes see yeah I'm a tar you might as
well just be a killer then want you don't have the heart in
you you just got you gotta shoot he's gotta shoot you don't
have the heart inside you the kill all right we gotta we
gotta start going in i think we gotta start shooting now or
what not all of us are worthy of continuing either oh i'm
trying someone landing right here yeah let's go oh some oh
they're ready oh i feel so bad the guy you killed already
already yeah they're like they're in there oh these guys are
truly hiding they're good all right i'm gonna shoot now done
playing with my food she's ready she's ready ready this is
it the zone is getting the plane is people spawning right oh
we just i'm coming
i'm sorry heavenly no heavenly i'm sorry i'm sorry are you
destroying him oh poor baby i'm i'm i'm a good spy i feel
really really bad right on me if you guys want to shoot him
he's right here i'm coming i'm coming yes assassin Oh, I'll
let her bleed out.
Oh, I feel so bad.
I feel so cruel.
I'm not gonna lie.
I feel really, really bad.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I just take out my shotgun when they're not looking and then
I blast them.
Yeah, and then you're like, goodbye.
I feel like a human fellow.
buddy kill confirmed sorry buddy i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
i'm gonna make some new friends i'll be right back i'm so
excited oh oh oh oh i'm in the oh oh get back in the ring
get back in the ring i don't have another res i'm a false
hiding i do have another res just heal if you do have i do i
do now oh my god there's 28 people left Oh my god.
Yeah, because we haven't killed anybody.
It's time to shoot your gun, Matara.
No more playing with food.
I need to heal first.
No more.
Matara, yeah, stop.
Yeah, stop playing with your food.
I gotta heal first.
I'm a liability.
Yeah, stop playing with your food, Matara.
Yeah, I have a Pathfinder.
I don't even know how to play.
They know.
Oh, they absolutely know.
Oh.
Oh, they absolutely.
He teleported near you, Doki.
He did.
All right, where is he?
No, he's not.
He's not.
Oh, he's over there.
Oh, I knocked him down.
Sorry, I'm going back up.
I'm taking you on the zip line.
You might want to take it before you.
I'm kind of going, come, come, come, come.
Where is it?
Can you tag it?
Right, okay.
I'm tagging.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
I found a lot of people.
There's a guy coming up to you guys.
Oh, SK.
They're all here.
Okay.
Maybe.
They're all on me.
All on me.
There's a lot of people on me too.
Oh, this is, this is, this is mean.
This is just the fun for the people who are searching.
I know, it feels so bad.
I feel so bad for them.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting paid to do this.
I'm not getting paid to do this.
Actually, I don't think we're getting paid for this round
right now.
It's getting fun.
It's fun.
No, we're not.
I'm getting pure enjoyment.
Ah, Doki's like, I don't need to.
Okay, they're back on the zip lines behind us.
They're like zip lining around back into the other places
and back out.
Got him.
Still people inside.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm starting.
I'm going to start fights now.
Now!
Now you're starting fights!
Right here.
Hello, friends!
Now you're starting fights?
Yeah, I have.
Bro, what happened to you?
like every other part where were the fights before uh
there's three of them on an island over here on an island
all right let's see increases ultimate effect all right guys
ready for the ultimate oh
I'm still mad.
And Doki's like, this is the plan.
Doki's like, please, next time we have this level again, but
the whole turn is over.
The whole turn is over.
I'll tell you, look up here.
Most likely they're there.
Look up.
Up top?
Yeah.
Kumihon!
I told you.
All right.
The zone.
Oh, okay.
One of our seekers is dead.
Listen, I gotta give them a chance to win.
I gotta give them a chance.
I feel too bad.
Give me all right here.
Someone should jump down again.
Come on, guys.
I can't be the only one.
I'm okay.
I gotta give, I gotta make it easier for them because it's,
I feel too bad.
Oh, you so lucky.
Yep, the stairs.
Red dot is so hard to use on this thing.
They're all burning!
Alright, you ready?
Little cockroaches.
We're almost there.
What do you think the rock up and all the little Sorry,
Japanese curry.
Are you ready?
Altair, you got to get ready over your alt.
Begin!
Oh, my God.
Oh, man.
Action!
Oh, shit.
Wait, I knocked myself down.
Wait, rest me?
Altair.
risky I'm gonna knock myself out one more time I got another
I got two more you guys are crazy you guys are crazy I died
I died I died oh my god wait there's that would have been so
funny if you One, new one.
Many are new.
He's going to let him do it a lot.
Come on.
Let's do it in the air.
Don't even show us all the way.
No.
Wow, guys.
I can't believe we got all the kills.
Who would have thought?
I think we should go pro.
I think this is the only win I'm ever going to get.
No, we're dead.
No, that's not true.
We got the win in the beginning.
True, true, true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, you're right.
You're right.
the Geneva Convention.
Raging Demon!
I...
I felt...
Oh my god.
Wait, why is my keyboard in GP?
Hold on.
Why...
Okay, wait.
Where's my keyboard in GP?
What's going on?
What did you do?
First place was Raging Demon, second place perfect, 13 Team
Manta.
Team Manta, yeah.
I made a friend and God betrayed.
Oh no.
I made a friend.
Oh!
I feel so bad.
A Tokyo also be heavy.
I had a good time.
I had a good time, guys.
We were just helping them reposition.
Amazing.
All right.
Last game, wild card.
Last game.
Joki, I need you to lock in and this is going to be your
first game.
You need more money.
We need a win.
We need a first place.
No, that's that.
You're asking a lot from me right now.
I am begging.
You're asking a lot from me.
All right.
This last game.
I did say it was three hours.
Thank God.
Even with the with all the the delay, it was all.
almost three hours.
Cool.
Thank God.
I'll be honest with you.
I didn't even know.
I'm, I'm just here for a good time.
Not a long time.
Oh, if we had Matara's Bangalore old, it would have been
perfect.
It would have been, this was the whole plan I had.
We had her Bangalore old.
How did you die?
She died.
Oh, I, I couldn't get back into the ring.
She wasn't in the hill.
I couldn't get back into the ring.
It would have been perfect.
We would have covered all the areas, you know, needed her to
get the back side.
I get the center.
Altair gets the other side.
I sort of pre-gamed the names though a little early.
I got too excited.
I still can't get over me and Altair be like, no, I feel
bad.
Adokie's like, yeah.
Oh, you should have seen what I was doing.
It felt good though, kind of like.
It felt really good.
But that's why we call it a sin, right?
my coffee from upstairs i'll ready us up okay don't worry
i'll say i'll read ready ready when lobby full i i literally
decided to games whoever i i tricked and backstabbed i'm not
sorry doki made me do it
what are you gonna look at me and telling me i'm Am I wrong?
Am I wrong?
She floated down in a bubble.
That was heavenly.
Hello.
Also, if anybody watched my VOD, they'd know that you are
not stacking your team to win.
That's all I gotta say.
You're a carry.
What are you talking about?
Enzone caustic ex-givial.
You're wrong.
We could have had bang for Matara.
what well yeah just died outside the finishing i can't type
anything i'm in like jp mode accidentally but matara he
patted on me off the slide that's crazy so funny hey no no
no no come on now he's trying to get early more like get
more food from me why do you why you do me like that you and
whatever Lena was.
Wasn't it fun, though?
Ain't it fun.
That was a diabolical game.
I'm very happy I wasn't a hiter.
See?
They had fun.
It works every time.
Matara burning to death.
It's true.
Your secrets are messed up.
Two of us are Canadian.
Yeah.
Geneva Convention who...
I claimed innocence.
Canadians.
The world most fire burning bug.
Whoever launch padded me into the lava.
That's really funny.
That's actually really funny.
We're ready.
I said ready whenever.
I said ready when lava before.
What do you think?
Yeah, that was really, really, really fun.
Apparently there was an octane that like launch pad everyone
into the lava.
That was so funny.
Because it's not against the rules.
but it's their job is to be the last person standing to win
more money but why wouldn't they do that that's actually a
genius idea yeah so they were the fact that end zone was the
lava fucked everybody up yeah no that's really genius let's
go through whatever that was i can't wait to see the vod all
right guys all right first place right last game last game
last one's like the wild card regular yeah it's the regular
we're punching people i'm playing watson again that's why
doki crazy last round that was her only round she could
shoot that's true that's true uh I can't use any abilities
so okay do not worry nobody will think that this was this
was a purposely stacked team okay so you can get first for
us is that the reasoning is that I just don't want you to
feel like oh you know I don't want them to worry that like I
rigged my own tournament yeah to go all out.
They would know you did not make this third.
You want me to go out right from the start instead of at the
end?
Is that?
You got to open it.
No, no, no, no.
At the end.
You know what I mean.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
So there's a wink in there, right?
Tara, are you winking?
I would like for us first place.
Are you?
Are you winking?
I would like to have a little bit of De Nero.
Let's win.
All right.
Here we go.
I would love a little bit of Deblunes to.
my name after this you know leblons all right three gold
leblons well you know what let's go to states i i jumped
early but it really doesn't matter yeah i was gonna say like
we just went straight up isn't actually i mean we can go
down here somebody's going okay you guys want to you guys
want to live for a while right yeah we want to live i'll
just survive we'll loot around this area i'm going to this
truck so you guys can peace off for me hi i'm piecing off
Because I'm grabbing abilities right off the bat.
You're punching the...
Oh, I forgot to equip the Hadook for the last game!
I keep going straight in.
I'm sorry.
Reset!
I keep forgetting to equip the...
I'm sorry.
I'm just...
Alright.
She's just a little guy.
Take it easy on her.
I'm just a little guy.
What the fuck got stuck?
Oh, they're already fighting.
Am I hearing footsteps from somebody else or from us?
I was right next to you.
Oh.
First blood.
It's Spitfire and Prowler good guns.
Prowl.
There are.
Yeah, they are.
I can keep them for like later.
Yeah, yeah, perfect.
All right.
leader with three kills already.
Oh, somebody got res though.
Darius is going in.
Alright, I'll show the Hadoopkin heirloom after this game
for you guys.
It's my bad.
I forgot to equip it.
Oh, on me, on me, on me.
On you coming?
Yeah.
You guys want to fight?
I mean, whatever you want.
Alright, let's go.
On me.
Over here, over here, over here, over here.
Cracked.
Oh, I got it.
No, it's sure for it.
All right.
You got him.
I got him.
One's cracked.
That's fine.
Back up.
Let's go.
That's sure for it.
Oh, they're fighting.
They're fighting.
Oh, yeah.
You want to heal or?
Yeah, I'm healing.
I'm healing.
Oh, I won two X.
Yeah, one of them is pretty low.
I'm coming up.
I mean, all right.
There they are.
Yep.
Got ya.
I know it's pure force already resed anyway, so I don't have
to.
Oh, hey, Gully.
Well, peekaboo.
Yeah.
Good job.
It was worth it.
All right.
Don't get in order to like grease.
It was worth it.
sure for it nuked down i know sure for is already res so
that's why i didn't mind killing gully oh but over there
yeah where regis is oh sorry i called you just oh they're
like a oh they have to be from far all right you can back
out i'm gonna heal up does it get close by i can't do
anything for now i need them to get close to me very very
close to death just uh just heal just Okay.
Just back out and heal.
I'm needed.
They're pushing.
They're over.
Okay.
I'm backing up.
Just just I'm going to sneak you.
Control.
I can run.
Woo!
Scary.
I'm respawning.
Okay.
Good.
Come to me.
Thank you.
All right.
refresh I'm coming you that is why that was almost good
because he can use be used to escape too so I'm gonna refill
this hello hello welcome back nice yeah it was nice and cool
very calming kill I got to see you killed me more coins you
guys want to keep fighting because we can fight yeah it's
fun let's go back in there let's go back in there i'm scared
but i'm going i think they're still there i'm pretty sure oh
my wait i'll tell you why wait when did you get valkyrie i
just wanted to try her out and i forgot i didn't have her
skin for her wait valk doesn't have a street fighter skin i
know wait they left valkyrie she's fun they left where did
they go he must have went the They got two of you guys, too.
They could have cheese.
Yeah, yeah, come with me.
Follow me.
Take this, take the zip.
Yeah, the zip, the zip, the zip, the zip.
Are you guys full on your ability points?
All right, take the zip, come with me.
There's people here who want to fight.
Hey, yeah.
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
They're running.
You're not.
They live here.
Oh, there's two.
There's two groups.
There is.
Yeah.
Because there's two, one of them was up.
Two down.
Wait, wait, leave them, leave them, leave them, leave them.
Leave them, leave them, leave them.
Leave them.
They're new players.
Behind us, behind us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just leave them.
Oh, one of them has a legendary trip take gun.
Should we grab that or is that?
Well, I can't grab it.
I- Do you want it from?
Yep.
You guys can grab it.
Behind us, behind us, behind us.
I gotta let them let them play a little longer Is the
carbine good?
Yeah, that's good.
It's long range.
I like the carbine What about the other one the the
legendary triple take?
Oh, it's a sniper.
Are you good with sniper?
Oh, no, it's not a sniper.
I'll tear it.
I'll tear it as a sniper.
I'm gonna grab the triple take is not a sniper though It is
it is.
It's a sniper shotgun.
It can be used as a shotgun.
Oh, they're shooting behind me behind me behind me Okay,
okay, okay.
Oh, I'm online, but I can't tell where they're shooting me
from
Careful, there were people down here.
Oh yeah, that's fun.
Live a little longer.
I'm okay for now.
All right, you guys want to get into, you guys want to get
into this, all right?
I'm here.
Follow me.
Is that okay?
I can just follow me.
Oh yeah, you can all just alt us.
Yeah, whatever.
Go over here.
Come here.
Come to me and then Alt here.
Me or him?
No, Altair.
He's going to fly us up into the air.
And then we'll go straight to the air.
So the triple take, let me see.
Is this...
Oh no.
No, wait, that's not triple take.
All aboard.
A, pricey.
So I just joined.
Yeah, and then we go up in the air.
We're going that way.
Go.
We're going up here.
Up here.
That's five.
Oh, I thought I was going with you guys.
Sorry, I had to do a little bit of evasive maneuvers.
For five.
Just stay here.
And then you're Watson.
So put your, come up here and put fences up here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know where zone's gonna end, so I'm chilling right
now.
People behind us.
Oh, there's a lot of people in right now.
Whoa.
Oh, I hear people on me.
Okay.
Wait, I need help, actually.
Oh, fuck.
I'm about to die.
One's real low.
I'm dead.
I'm reviving.
I'm coming back.
I might use a live.
I'll tear.
Okay.
Stay back.
I'm a reset warning.
trying to live not just survive for five five seconds we're
good we're good i fucked up my own so there was like i
landed super close to my monitor oh yeah it wasn't good area
okay so we're gonna stay here uh you fence up around us yeah
yeah just fence here uh wait tara come over here just fence
this area for now um i'm gonna think a little like that yeah
yeah and then too let's back here let me check around
because i don't want b on low ground because i feel that
it's a little too dangerous for us oh my quinn i don't have
enough fences to fence the whole thing it's fine we just
just chill i think if you drop your ultimate you can get
more fences right really every time i'm gonna drop this is
that still a thing yeah but i don't think you need it in a
protected place yeah we don't need we don't need it no we
don't need it anyway i mean just I'm just gonna chill.
Hold on, I'm chilling.
Let's see.
Oh, there's a team here.
If you guys want to fight.
There's a team here.
You want to fight them or no?
Sure.
All right.
Let's do it.
Let me if I drop my ult.
Right here.
On me?
Right here?
Uh, perfect.
Oh, okay.
I dropped it.
And we can go back to it.
Right here.
Got a bad guy.
I'm still going up to him.
I got a need.
He's ready to fight.
Oh my god.
Oh, I need to leave.
I need to leave.
Oh, no.
I'll tell you gotta live.
I'll tell you.
I also died like instantly.
Oh my god.
I fucked up.
I fucked up there.
You have to live.
I'll tell you.
You just live.
Just live.
I died instantly, y'all.
I don't even know what I did.
Okay, I'll tell you.
Just live.
Don't go.
Don't look back.
Just run.
Oh, who's not here?
I'll tell you.
You're fucking madman.
13 seconds.
Oh.
I'll tear your...
Oh, no!
He's gonna die!
No!
You're fighting!
I'm like, why did you lie back?
I'm like, I was chasing me.
I'm sorry.
He was chasing me.
I had to jump off and he jumped off and kicked me.
All right, so, guys, we're out.
We're...
Well, you know what?
At least nobody can accuse you of stacking up the team.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
We did pretty good.
so i was trying to throw a grenade and then the door closed
so i stood in the grenade that i did oh okay yeah that's a
little awkward because i was running behind you and then you
close the door behind you oh did i i didn't even realize i
closed it betrayal or maybe i fucked up there i ran it's
okay it was i still had fun i had a great time they can't
say i raised the tournament you know exactly like you know
they can't say that thank you for hosting and thank you for
inviting me let's see how it plays out yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly of course of course how do i is it just live yeah
there you just go live yeah yeah i'm expecting mr raffle
waffles right now I'm spectating spectating flats it's not
rigged yeah it's not rigged exactly that's how you know yeah
I might have trolled a little bit I got a little
bloodthirsty there it's okay it was fun it is what it is
what an end zone you know I also think about it like at the
end of the day not every person in this tournament is a very
big creator so you know like I'm sure first place prize
money means to some people than dyrus i'm throwing you under
the bus than dyrus not a big career well wait but dyrus did
win first though he did what you know what i mean so i i
think it it's uh it's nice i really do hope that no guys we
didn't okay we didn't die to the team we spared guys we
didn't die to team we spared we died the sk's team maybe
this is all just karma because of what we did
guys we were fighting SK's team okay they're all running
look look I want them we we lived all the way to the end on
all the other games right guys so we you know we're giving
them a chance to live to the end but I had a money for
everyone yeah the adrenaline was awesome thank you for
inviting me you know I'll tear again trying to invite Matara
to tournament like at least four times now but it always
happens so but in my defense she'll be like are you free in
two days and i'm like that is true no i gave you like two
weeks i gave you two weeks for one of them yeah so yeah
exactly sometimes a lot of times i would have like a sponsor
or they're right like taking time off to do like concert or
something i'm like oh oh wait they got wait thank you for
joining yeah it was so much i really think like the laughs
were just a plus did you have fun meeting altair for the
first time yeah hi oh hi i'm altair read us altair from holy
stars i hope people had fun even with the delays and
everything i just think about apex there are down times if
you do die first so i hope everyone had a chance to to like
not have downtime guys use your the entire purpose is to use
your fist guys yeah they're like they're they're I
Kill fight win just start brawling I should have made one
where everybody had to fight but then I had to punch Yeah, I
think that would have been nice around where like instead of
using melee We would actually be using the big punches.
I think that would have been.
Yeah I did that I only did that because I wanted like that
those who aren't like not have a chance to like shoot back
against like the better players, you know?
That's why I did that rule.
But I'm like, everybody's like, I'm too scared to punch
right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What is happening?
There's so many things going on.
Oh my god, everybody's just punching.
Everybody's just punching.
Like, who got first?
Oh my god, everybody that I'm spectating dies.
And I'm like, no!
Better off.
I'm going to spectate next is going to die.
It's so true.
They're still pressing.
Please.
Everybody I spectate has died.
Oh, that's heartbreaking.
Wait, who got first?
Who was it?
I didn't even see the name.
It went by so fast.
It went by everyone I spectate.
It also got died.
Right?
Let's go.
Oh, let's go.
Good job.
I think Sang is a pro, so that makes sense.
That's awesome.
they live i'm running around yeah all right the best part is
i got a bunch of skins courtesy of apex legendary ha ha ha
apex legendary apex bill legendary gg yay yay yay thank you
for the hosting And thanks.
Yippee.
Oh my god.
SK's team fucking went nuclear.
They had to be farmed several off of us.
Wow.
Do you feel like you can finally breathe now?
I'm glad it's done.
I'm just glad.
You should go sleep.
I don't know.
But thank you for it.
you guys want to do one more game i need to showcase the
heirloom all right let's do one more but not all right all
right wait i need to feed my dog real quick i'll be right
back go go go go no problem i'm here for anything you need
girl it's 7 30 eastern like we're good oh she left yeah it's
okay it's for the dog but yeah i i love it after this it is
7 30 eastern so usually if i need an excuse to like bail out
of something and i'm somewhere i'll be like sorry guys i
gotta go home and feed my cat i don't have a cat but it's
you know or i'll be like guys i'm sorry i gotta go home i
gotta feed my neighbor's dog it's so busy yeah i'm sorry
guys i gotta i gotta feed yeah my neighbor's rack i gotta
feed my oven that i left running um i think i think yeah i
got i got some pies cooking in the basement i gotta go i'm a
vtuber i gotta get I'm back guys.
Welcome back.
All right, Matara, accept my invite.
Oh, let me change my character.
Where are we?
I have to leave the, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You gotta leave the custom lobby.
Actually, I don't want to put in that.
I'm gonna be easy.
Predator grind when right now you're watching it happen.
I don't know if that's a smart idea, Matara.
You're gonna lose your fucking mind.
No, no, no.
I mean, you saw me lose my mind.
lose your mind oh i'm too paranoid for this let's see i
might play like i might play like a little bitch if
everybody's playing like a little i'm gonna go watch my
raccoon do taxes sorry i gotta go but you wake up all right
is that duken melee quick forever only i think only i have
the
I'll show you guys my Hadookan.
Oh, oh, girl.
I mean, I'm an idol.
Hey, guys.
You want to see my Hadookan?
Yes.
The Hadookan, girl.
Girl.
Please, Hadookan.
Is that how you tell everybody wink wink?
Oh, I don't know.
i don't kiss and tell guys i don't how are we like at the
end of the player skill distribution how i literally
finished her wait when i was doing my um my placements i was
at the other end completely guys i um by the way i messed up
this is not the right game mode so we gotta leave i just
realized where we're at i pressed are you sure press escape
yeah it's supposed to be wild press escape and leave match
whoops that was my bad all right now ready i was like wait a
minute all right i'm ready that's not it no problem dd
freaking easy man i really like this this like home page
though it looks really really i don't know it looks so cool
yeah i should have like retroactively changed the role on
the last one being like no guns for anyone.
In hindsight, I do think if we had a match of just using the
street fighter fighting, it would have been so fun.
It would have been so.
Yeah, yeah.
And I think that's also where like, of course, you know, the
pros that are really good at shooting games have, you know,
still an advantage of knowing the map, knowing the running
tech and stuff like that.
But I think it would have like made it a lot more open.
The reason why it did was just because like I wanted to give
like people who are not AP.
players a fighting chance against because like you know they
the people were masters plus they don't have a gun so at
least they can shoot at them because then like shoot back at
them and stuff so i didn't think everybody would just start
using gun because when i was doing these games when i was
more like doing these trying it out no one really everyone
was just brawling so i like no one was actually like for
funsies right so no one was actually brawling like
everyone's brawling so i never came into my head that people
would the gun was like an option because i I would hot drop
estates and just fucking beat everybody up and like no one
really to change character doki.
Oh, no, you play whatever character you want Okay, you can
double watch maybe that's just bias on how you play doki No,
but like no, I was you just see everyone fighting because
you're fighting.
I was playing these games You were joining games where
people were trying the new game mode to see how it works And
now you're in a lobby where people who are pros of the game
are gonna always go at like what they're best at right?
Yeah, but then the pros are on melee only though.
That's the thing so I didn't in my head anything like the
newer players would also like go like fully gun mode you
know you know go in i still think you did a really really
great job with just like in high say type yeah yeah oh it's
heavenly father thank you for the 27 months wow you were
great lovely lovely to see you i'm sorry we meet in the
fields of battle all right hot drop this is where war starts
right here this is like the for um oh boy so we are all hey
someone has my skin oh sorry sorry i fucked up the drop
the dokey bird skin she's like yeah all right all persons go
to your local don't know there you go i have it now i don't
know how to tell you this dokey but there other people with
us.
Watch this, guys.
We're fine.
Please stop watching, Heavenly.
Oh, behind, behind.
Watch this.
I don't know where.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm playing the game right now.
Look at that.
Yeah.
And then look at this, guys.
Oh, my God.
I am so...
Wait, I didn't move my coffee cup!
Oh, my God.
This is so bad.
All right, now...
They're coming!
Yep, yep, I should have just died.
Just die, just die.
Die!
You take out.
I'm dying, I'm dying.
Sorry, I did take my coffee cup.
So it's actually on me.
I should have just started- why are you even using a gun?
Yeah, why are you?
I'm literally here to punch a guy in the throat.
I don't discriminate.
Why am I using guns?
Exactly.
I'm just here.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god, I haven't used my gun in so long.
I don't remember how to shoot my gun.
I actually don't remember how to shoot my gun.
Run.
Risha, I died again.
There you go.
Oh my god, I can actually fight back.
Oh no.
Yeah, I killed it.
Man, I love this respawn.
Wait, how are we back so quick?
Because I killed somebody.
Ah, I got it back.
Whoa.
So if I kill somebody, you guys get into spawn back.
Oh my god, they're all dropping here.
Lo, lo, lo, lo, lo.
All right.
Risha.
Oh no.
Just killing everyone.
He's coming down here.
It's so silly.
It's actually so silly.
They're all dropping here.
Yeah, that's why I'm saying this.
I love playing it on this specific map, like right in the
States, because it's just a lock of fucking brawl.
See, like everybody's just fisting, you know?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, where are they?
Oh, not me.
Oh, you think you can run?
yeah get street fired right oh I might be dead oh shit okay
I might be dead here no I got you I got you oh I need a
better gun I need a better gun okay it's five is that i'm
gonna rest and smoke you got your life so it's five it is
like old school skull town it is
oh my god bitch this double jump really messes with me oh
wait which one which one are you using uh the reu guy oh
yeah i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead it's fine just just
sad your your response are so fast it'll be five Exactly.
It doesn't really matter.
Oh shit.
I got...
Oh no!
He was one!
You got him!
Oh no!
He was one!
He's one!
Yes!
Yeah!
Wait, I'm dead.
It's fine.
I'm here.
It's okay.
I'll respawn in five.
Just keep fighting.
Yeah.
I'm back.
Oh.
Oh
Goodbye, I got again.
Okay, don't worry.
Oh shit.
Watch me in a bar Oh my god that fucking people are figuring
out some actual meta of this game now It's the game.
Which is what?
What is the meta?
It's literally the Watson shit.
That's the whole thing.
Oh, the barricading yeah but I need I need his coins give me
your coins hey give me your coins kid give me your lunch
money that's right give me their lunch money yeah oh
somebody shooting at me oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait my don't touch me I'm sorry I couldn't get it is it
going safe because of the game mode or because of.
We gotta go.
It's the, it's basically the timing of the round.
So as the round takes down, the zone, the respawn timing,
it's higher.
I'm dead.
I got it.
Stay alive, stay alive, stay alive.
I'm all right.
I'm alive.
I'm very much alive.
Wee!
I'm alive again!
I'm trying to catch up with you, Doki.
Oh, it's fine.
You have to go.
We have to go in zone anyway.
You're fine, you're fine.
You're fine.
Nope.
You're not fine.
No, he got me with the dog.
I'm going in.
Yeah, just respawn.
Oh, the respawn time is higher now.
So I'm coming over here.
I'm going to the coin trap.
Yeah, people figured out the meta.
When people didn't know the meta of this game, it was people
actually just brawled it out.
It's fine.
But where's the raid?
Oh, they're cracked.
Is he running away?
Not.
There you go, I got him.
I need his stuff.
There's a guy up there, I think.
All right, I need your coins.
Oh, I'm okay.
Up top, up, up, up, up, up.
Oh, shit, I'm no longer okay.
I'm no longer okay.
No, don't kill him.
It's okay.
No, no, no, no, no, don't be here.
I'm going.
No, don't be here.
Let her respond.
Let her respond, right?
We're running.
I'm recharging my shields.
Oh, they're behind me.
They're shooting slowly.
Tactical recharge.
Yeah, tactical retreat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
I'm three seconds.
Three seconds.
Where are you?
All right.
I'm here.
Oh, God.
Run, run, run, run, run.
We're running.
Okay, perfect.
Running, running, running.
Suppressive fire.
I'm landing on a coin truck right now.
I died.
Run, run, run, run.
Run.
Will you be okay?
No, she's alive.
She's alive.
I'm alive.
Okay, like what about Matara?
Oh, Matara's not alive.
I'm leaving Never mind Matara.
I have to leave you Leave me leave me leave me.
I have to leave you.
I think I probably should have like, uh, I don't know I'm
just here for the for the for the company.
It's all right.
It's all right I'm going to welcome back.
Welcome back Altair.
Yeah tactical relocation exactly We're relocating I got it.
Oh.
You guys are in the building, right?
I'm greedy.
I took off all the coins.
I'm ready to fight.
She's ready to fall.
People go three Watson's though.
At least we went two Watson's.
We're a little better.
I don't really count as a Watson.
I'm just here for the zip line.
All right.
Let's see.
Is that yours?
Okay.
That's mine.
My fences are blue.
Do you want to stay here?
Okay, we can catch these guys.
Yeah, we can.
Wait, I'm not I'm not going that.
Somebody pass.
No, I don't know.
No, they're in zone.
They're in zone.
We can just wait.
There's behind us.
There's guys behind us.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's fine.
Run.
I'm fine.
from the from the font today what's that brave sir altair
ran away shut up listen at this point we just need one of us
to pee around so we all respawn so that is very exactly i'm
so brave what the fuck you actually did good okay there's
someone is everything okay i'm okay and she bravely ran away
um tactical relocated away um please get that correct Oh my
god, they're behind that bin.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh wait, he's tactically trying to stay alive for his team
too.
Right here?
Okay.
Right there.
This is like so tough to see them when they're far the
enemies.
I don't know how you guys have such a trained eye.
When they start moving, it's weird.
Because then it's like static and then suddenly something is
moving.
That's how I can see it.
I need like coins.
Yeah, but like when you're used, like I'm still like just
trying to figure out where I'm walking half the time.
It's just the still of memory.
It's just you play it so much.
It just...
Yeah, you just, yeah, remember stuff.
Yeah, that is definitely...
That's usually how it is.
Once you level up.
It's the same with like a lot of games, too.
We're like, once you kind of get used to what stuff looks
like, it gets a little bit...
But yeah, so you're like oh, I you like see stuff and you
like remember what where everything is located and you're
just like wait a minute that shouldn't be here You know,
you're like huh that looks different and also your movement
becomes more automatic where you kind of understand where to
go Exactly Oh, wait, are you guys still there?
Oh my god, okay guys have to live you guys have to live like
someone literally landed straight at me while just fucking
around You guys have to live.
I actually got landed on.
Just live for 21 seconds.
Oh, Altair, he'll heal you.
I'll take you here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was just covering.
I literally got like three men landed on.
Oh, I'll be back.
Still down there.
Because they were right here.
They landed right on me.
I was just like, where am I?
Where did they come from?
like army right here like they all respawn here you're not
in zone guys oh oh oh yeah come over here come over into the
i'm coming uh look around i'm safe you guys want to come
here oh my god i don't have health kids okay we're gonna
we're gonna oh wait this is actually not safe oh wait that's
a window i got too dark didn't realize that was a window i
have to go in we shall they're but I'm sorry I had no idea
what I'm doing it's okay it's okay 30 seconds you're good oh
I'm not good then I didn't realize you guys are dead I'm
safe I'm safe you're safe all right yeah we just got caught
off in rotation no worries it's good it's a confusing time
they also like put a grenade at the door so I kind of oh my
yeah they're so good I'm living like Larry right now her
yeah i love it my child's like abandon her fence up the door
stay away from her keep her in danger we're fine
everything's fine over here
everything is fine yeah come over to me oh my god i didn't
realize i thought you were like okay i for some reason
thought he was alone i don't know what i was teaching i Oh
my god, you got fucking gunned down.
Wait, I think I just...
I thought I was, like, cutting that guy by himself.
I just downed two people.
Nice.
They have a weird angle.
I mean, what's that?
Oh, that's the guy that fucking landed on.
Oh.
He's shooting at me.
I'm going to my...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, wait, I don't have shields.
I wasn't linked.
He has shields.
shields?
Because I wasn't looting shields.
Oh yes.
There's two.
Thank you.
One shields.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
That's fun.
One down.
Oh, yeah.
Res me fast.
We're in diamond zone.
We're good.
We're good here.
Matara's back.
All roots inside are fighting.
Do not die.
We can't die.
Oh, shit.
Across.
Oh my god.
I'm just placing my shields and like hoping for the best.
Okay.
Do you have your ultimate?
Yeah.
I don't.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
Good luck.
Everybody good luck.
Thank you.
I have a...
Okay.
Come to me.
We need a needle.
Wait, wait.
You can raise Matara.
She's ready.
I'm going to him.
I'm going to go.
I'm going to raise him.
On Doki, on Doki.
No, he got off!
He got the off!
Oh, no!
I can't kill him.
He's got a shield.
He had off!
No!
I didn't even see him.
I wouldn't have fucking...
halted there.
Oh.
Stupid Akuma on.
Good job.
Oh, my God.
Gigi.
I got fucked over by the Akuma.
It's okay.
Did you show off the stuff that you wanted to show off?
I got to show my little Hadouken.
Because I'll be honest, I don't think I got another one in
me.
This game was so good, but it's stimulating.
It's intense.
It was intense, but thank you for joining me.
I really appreciate it.
thank you for being on my team and for uh uh coming in so
last minute to play with me it was awesome tournament i'm
really really glad thank you guys thank you yeah it's always
fun playing games yeah i had so much fun i can't wait to
re-watch um like a compilation of our collab today would i
need to pick me up just be a good one yeah thank you guys i
really appreciate all you guys
Being there, my crazy journey of having a week to put all of
this together.
While everybody is busy, because it's like games are
launching.
People have stuff to do.
People are traveling.
Taking their time out of their schedule for coming to the
tournament.
I really appreciate it.
And, you know, in hindsight, there's a lot of things that we
have definitely changed and stuff going in.
You'll know.
I mean, it's always easy, right, when you're like, oh, I
would do this different again.
Yeah, because you're really thinking, like, I don't know, I
was thinking, like, everybody's going to start brawling
right like who's going to use your gun and then i was like
oh apparently everyone end of the day it was fun so yeah it
was fun yeah i'm glad like everyone had fun and um and you
know everybody uh enjoyed themselves thank you alex thank
you guys it was fine have a good one okay one more i'm gonna
solo one more but thank you guys i really I really
appreciate it.
Bye-bye.
GGs, guys.
Bye.
GGs.
All right.
Okay, I'm going to do one more.
Guys, I'm going to do one more.
Goddamn Watson's everywhere.
Goddamn Watson's roaming around.
To be fair, I'm part of the problem, too.
uh but yeah it was you know obviously i'm um i wish i like
obviously you know i'm a perfectionist i'm very hard on
myself because i always want to improve myself and you know
i always feel bad when scuff happens and stuff like that um
and um i always feel bad but i do hope even then people
still had fun um like i said i did wish i made it so that
last wildcard match like nobody carried i really wish i
could see what that looked like uh i'm just like i'm beating
myself up right now it's like ah and i wish i got to see
what it would look like uh if uh if we had a game where
everyone just used mainly but i was like worried that uh
like in my head i was just like oh i just want people to
have a fighting like people who don't play apex have a
fighting chance and um be able to shoot back if needed um
What every game was its own prize.
I don't know who won which one because the standings aren't
updated.
So I just know that first place was Shuriken Spammers, which
I believe is...
It's Seng's team.
And the second was Heavenly's team.
Let's see.
And then it did make me realize the power level of people
too.
But at that point, at that point, I was like hoping to, I
already had so many people to dropping out and recruiting
people was really, really hard.
And at that point, at one point, I was just like,
grabbing whoever's willing.
to say yes yeah grabbing whoever was willing to be like yeah
i got this um and you know i'm just i'm just glad it's over
i'm just glad we were one week of getting everything yeah i
did the best with what we had yeah and uh i really
appreciate everyone participating because like I said oh a
lot to a lot of people for you know giving their time to
watch and like giving their time to participate giving their
time to watch and then just I guess like being there you
know so really appreciate it um yeah that's I can rest a
little bit.
I'm thinking if I'm going to, I don't know.
I'm so tired.
I had like barely any sleep the last three days.
I had barely any sleep the last three days.
Every day was just hell.
Every day.
You don't understand.
Yesterday I spent 12 p.m.
to 5 a.m.
just messaging people non-stop over.
And just, I, just, non-stop messaging people just from last
night just to grab everyone together yeah yeah but i learned
a lot from organizing this one um i think like definitely
for sure i think i'm gonna change it so that everyone has a
chance to win money um and uh i know i made it like i the
first place i think next time i want to make it so like
everyone's placement is restricted like every like it's like
single prize limitation like full prize limitation so like
every team has a chance to uh has a chance to like win money
i think that would have been a better system i did each game
and just limited first prize place because at that time i
was i wanted to change the rules
They were like, we can't change anymore, but I wanted to
change the rule one more time to make it, like, all prizes
be limited.
But again, at that time, it was too late.
It was like, I already used my one last change.
My one last change was to make it a Street Fighter set.
Yeah.
I wanted to do it so that all prizes were limited.
Because I thought about it.
And I was like, okay, we limited all the prizes.
and everybody could at least win some form of money.
By that time, I already used my one change.
I already used my one change to add a set, to add a Street
Fighter set in the...
I would definitely move the Street Fighter, the Boxing Ring
Royale at the end.
I would have moved that to the end.
Or not even at the end.
I would have moved that, like, in the middle instead of
putting it in the beginning, because I didn't realize how
long it would take to set up and I just wanted to get that
going um because I I know a lot of people also I told them
like I can only do it up to this time and then we have I
have to go and I was like okay yeah um we're gonna try my
best to end it at that time and so I was really worried
because I was like tick tock yeah um I was just like oh shit
tick tock but even then it was still three hours I went in
at around threeish hours which is By the way, this game
mode, you can farm 4k and 20 bomb.
I farmed, I accidentally, I accidentally got a 4k 20 bomb on
a, on conduit, on the, on my first day playing this game
mode.
I was not expecting that.
So if you guys never got a 4k 20 bomb, this is the game mode
to do it.
I wonder they nerfed some stuff.
Because like, I want to, I felt like it was so much, a lot
easier getting, my power-ups when the game the modes first
came out when we accidentally when the game mode first came
out everyone was just brawling there was no fucking meta i
literally i like didn't even do like a challenge with the
gun i just went straight in booted up my ability and just
started brawling that people and i got a 4k 20 buff like i
didn't even um like i didn't try I, too.
Oh my god, I fucking hate.
I hate.
I hate this meta.
I actually...
I hate this Watson meta.
Where's the whimsy of Adokie your watch?
Because I...
If I can't beat him, I have to join.
him what happened to straight up fighting what happened to
the good old days where we would just fucking brawl i'm
rolling in like this my turn oh where are you oh that's
right i got the arms of the angel
Just fucking right get over here.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh shit I didn't grab a gun.
Oh no he's shooting back.
Okay that's fine.
Oh I need a gun.
I forgot about that.
See this is why I mean all I did was just brawl.
I didn't care.
No I need to shoot my gun back I guess.
I guess I'll shoot my gun.
I guess it's not as fun though give me my fucking fist I
remember like when the mode did they nerfed it up in because
I remember when the game mode first came out I can just
charge it up instantly I don't know oh my god fuck it was so
close I got so greedy I got so fucking greedy
Wait, am I buffering on YouTube?
I don't know why that's happening.
Have I been buffering the entire day?
It is.
It is a lot of bug getting up close and personal.
That's right.
Because I don't know.
I remember I could just charge it up.
I just...
They did?
Oh!
Oh wait, it's buffering?
Wait, really?
I don't know why.
Is it just me?
Is it just been, uh, is it just been, uh, me?
Or, like, is it for everybody else?
It's a YouTube issue?
Is everyone else also in other channels?
Oh, that's so unlucky.
I told you!
Anything that could go wrong has gone wrong for me, guys.
I fucking told you!
I'm so unlucky.
Everything...
Okay, Devotion is so broken.
I...
I told you, everything that's gone wrong for me, the last
three days, all related to, like, getting this tournament
sorted out and everything has literally been nerfing me so
hard.
It's actually crazy.
Even this morning, I spilled my drink on the floor, too.
I've always had low-latency mode on.
You were supposed to always have low-latency mode on.
It's actually crazy.
I've been nerfed the entire day.
My power level is not there yet.
I'm back.
That's not me.
Fuck, I died already.
I forgot I died already.
I'm back, guys.
Like, wait a minute.
Let's see.
I'm trying to think, like...
Alright, after this game, we're gonna...
I'll do one more.
I do one more.
I'm done with the Watson life.
I'm gonna play the character that's broken in this game
mode.
Coffee's losing its effect.
Yeah.
I guess.
Yeah, my team is gone.
Yeah, I was going to say, I'm back.
I'm being res back.
I was like, wait a minute.
I didn't play Vantage.
I want to do one more.
That's it.
I'm losing my Watson shackles.
I'll play the character I usually play in this game mode.
That I think is even more broken.
Do they nerf this mode a little?
Or...
Okay.
Deal damage to save power.
Yeah, deal damage to save power up longer.
I don't remember.
Like, would save power up much longer?
Okay, I would usually play conduit because the shield is so
broken.
Conduit or...
You know what?
I'll do Pathfinder.
Fuck it.
Because I'm using that.
I've never tried Pathfinder in this.
But I would play a conduit for this mode just because, like,
the shield on top.
It's so broken.
I still can't believe the guy.
We gave him the free coin packs.
And he bought the pack.
Sorry, we even free coins.
And he bought the packs instead of the skins.
Like, that's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
And he was like, I don't have any of those skins.
And we're like, what?
He was like, I opened all the packs and I didn't get any.
like i'm like bro you can literally buy the skin it went
straight to gambling and fucking just just ripped it
and we're like bro the skins were right there
heavily i got like caught too because i was like we're going
to the next game mode fuck it and they're like please do not
confirm anything without a browser oh shit i'm in trouble oh
my god i'm serious my bitch oh i'm fine
oh you're such a little bitch you're such a little bitch boy
is there any coins near me oh they farmed all the coins Oh,
no, it was a pro player that did that.
That's why I thought it was even funnier because it was a
pro.
Oh.
Oh, oh, you got the window.
A window.
The window's got me.
Oh, God.
I need...
Oh, he took all the coins!
I'm dead.
I couldn't.
Oh, wait.
What?
Are you sick?
Oh, shit.
That was close.
That was so close.
That's fine.
I just don't have any coins, though, so I'm not as fine as I
should be.
Why use gun?
Just fist fight.
Oh.
All right.
Whatever.
Oh, whatever.
Little does he know.
I'm part of that.
Oh, goddammit.
Little do I know.
It's fine.
Respond.
Okay.
Well, he's gotta live.
Or...
Oh, and he lives.
By the time I fly down.
I need more coins.
where the fuck are they oh wait i have coins now all right
where is he oh my god those bitch ass with your goddamn guns
bitches with your guns a course oh my god i want i want to
fist them oh my god all right
That's it.
I'm going over.
Oh my god, my loot.
Where are they?
I don't care.
Give me your coin.
I need as many of the coins as possible.
Alright, there you go.
I just want to punch.
That's it.
Oh, you're so fucking lucky.
You're so lucky.
Oh my god.
Oh, get fucking tunnel vision.
My teammate was right behind me.
Oh yeah, not so fun now.
Is it?
I'm finishing you.
I'm, if it's the last thing I do, I'm gonna.
Oh, yes.
I don't care.
Oh.
That's it.
I don't care.
Get over here.
Get over here!
Where is he?
Oh, stop!
Get over here!
I've had enough!
There you go.
I'm good.
Everything's fine.
All right, we're fine.
We're okay.
Oh, I Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, he's
so lucky.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Give me your coins.
Where is he?
Oh, he's so, oh, you're so lucky.
You're so lucky you have a team.
away to these stress okay they need to get killed i remember
when when the mode first launched uh you can charge up your
ability a lot faster i mean to be fair it is very broken
though it's very broken i legit was just the moment you have
one good fight the moment you have one good fight you're
you're just it's like never ending gauge i literally have
one fight and then it's just always fully powered up and
maybe it wasn't as fair with that but it was very fun it was
very very fun just eating people up non-stop okay
oh my god a fucker that fucker I knew anything I have to
heal this never-ending fight I don't have enough gauge for
this I'm going in I don't know what they're saying oh maybe
not maybe not leaving oh shit never mind I'm not going in
all right we're five
Yes, I'll use my fucking gun.
God.
Okay, over here.
Me and my shit.
Give me your coins.
You're witches!
I let him kill me like that!
Come on!
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Let's get it.
That's good.
A moment.
That's not good.
That is not good.
Our guy has to live now.
Our...
Okay.
We're okay.
12 seconds.
Just gotta live 12 seconds.
He's got this.
Um, we're so poor.
We're so fucking poor.
I need that coin truck right now.
Right now.
I need a fire of this.
Hey.
Alright, let's see.
That's fine.
Oh, that's golden.
Okay, I didn't mean any of that.
Okay.
All right.
Wait, he's beating them up.
Oh, okay.
Oh my.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit!
Oh, this is bad for me though.
I don't want to go in there.
They're fucking brawling right now.
That's right, I brought a gun to, oh shit.
Where did he go?
Wait, he disappeared.
What the fuck?
Where did the guy go?
He actually fucking disappeared.
I just been so long since I played Pathfinder, I'm like, how
the fuck do I play this character again?
Go in there, it's like the shiv insta shot.
Where did he go?
I'm ready.
Oh, I'm no longer ready, I'm no longer ready.
This guy's a fucking divo because he does not get bitches in
life.
Alright, I'm coming with help.
wait okay this is bullshit because like what oh i fucked up
when you have melee on you can't spam melee and see at the
same time which is very bullshit i didn't like not like that
oh nice oh me bro i've been fighting the same dude all game
There's like no clue like where you guys are fighting.
Oh no, I am going back.
I'm going up here.
Alright.
I need to make sure our guys stay alive.
Before I do anything.
The guy is funny to say that it's like the battle of the
century.
It truly is the bad of the century right now.
What the fuck was that?
What did I just see?
All right.
All right, let's see.
Oh my god, you serious?
If that guy didn't third party, I would kill them!
I'm back, I'm your...
Alright, nice go.
What?
I had so much HP!
What killed me?
I actually don't know what killed me.
Where are we, bro?
my eye i don't have any more though i'll give him the coin i
don't have any though like the cat fist anymore this thing's
gone jesus i'm gonna delete it from afar and yeah i don't
have shoes that's actually bad for me whatever
Oh, nice.
Yeah!
We did it!
The guy got so mad in the fucking wildcard game mode.
Yippee!
You know what?
That's a good game to end.
All right, that's it.
Yeah.
It all worked out in the end.
Let's go.
All right, we're done.
sleep no shit no no no no no no no no no okay wait i
actually clicked cute oh no tell okay i'm out i'm out no
okay i'm out i'm out i'm out that's a that's an intense game
to end on with my teammates yelling at me uh after everybody
was like cheering me on my own team um but i find y'all for
coming to the tournament um i pulled it off somehow
obviously there's some stuff i would have loved to change
because that's just me being critical about myself because
if I had more time that's when I polished a lot more with
this tournament but like I said I cobbled everything with
duct tape and hot glue and here we go yeah um and I still
hope everyone had fun I'm gonna DM personally DM everyone
just uh just to thank everybody for participating and I hope
you guys had fun watching too uh i hope all of you guys had
fun watching like i said huge shout out to the players who
uh participated huge shout out to the devs uh to apex and
mouth live for uh joining this wild ride putting everything
together uh with me and there's always room for improvement
um you know there's always like stuff that went wrong a lot
of stuff went wrong for me in the last three days uh but we
got through it we got through it guys and in the end we made
it to the finish line i hope uh i hope everyone had fun
watching and check out the game mode too um thank you all
for thank you like i said thank you all i really do
appreciate everybody who participated i just have no idea i
messaged 50 plus people i more than 50 plus i think i
messaged like definitely like 70 people because I had to get
30 and I felt like grabbing that 30 was one of the hardest
things I've ever done for a tournament.
I've never struggled so hard.
I shot messages to like more than 70 people and we made it.
We made it.
And I'm so glad we made it.
I'm so glad we had something in the end.
And I owe a lot of people, a lot, huge, I owe a lot of
people a lot for coming in clutch too, for doing this for
me.
And yeah, it was, it's fun playing with Matara and Altair.
It's fun just talking with them, yapping with them.
It's fun trolling them a little bit.
Like I said, I went in, I didn't want to like, went in just
wanted to like make sure other play teams were having fun.
That's why I let people go.
I didn't want, I didn't try hard.
I just like be like, oh, don't kill them.
Or like I let Matara and Altair do all the killing and
stuff.
And I just fucked around jumping around and I was just
jumping around, just doing my own thing and like, because I
want people to have fun and I, I want to be able, um, you
know, and I like, I recognize names and stuff.
So I was like, when I see like people I know who don't have
a lot of experience in any place, that's why I let them live
because I was just like you know I wanted to I wanted them
to have a longer chance in the game because I knew like I
didn't want them you know we got first eliminated but I was
fine with that um we already had a lot of top four finishes
so I was just like I'm just fine not having a top four
finish because I want you know I like people I want people
to have more of a chance to do well yeah um so thank you all
for supporting the tournament thank you all for watching
thank for supporting everybody else as in the tournament you
shout out to everybody who participated i really appreciate
everyone for being part of this and uh for being in the
journey i don't know if i'll do another last minute
tournament after that um unless i i'll be like what's in it
for me you know yeah you know i'll be like all right what's
the trade offer because i was So stressed out.
I really was.
So stressed out there.
And it was.
Oh my.
The fact that.
All of this got.
This happened still.
As always.
Everybody stay hydrated.
Poster check out.
I'm around.
that blood flowing is there for me at tibet guys you deserve
it thank you guys again i really appreciate it with some
thank you dms to everybody who participated um because like
i said it really does mean a lot because you know and i i
even if like some people didn't have fun um i i i hope they
know that i really appreciate that they gave their time to
be part of the event um and you know it it was like scuffed
or something like i do appreciate them um you know being
there till the end as well so um so i like i said i'm really
thankful i'm just really thankful for all the people that
stuck it to the end with me like going and knowing that i
did tell that i wanted them advanced like i cobbled all of
this together like within a week i told them like this
tournament i've made it i made this in a week so i'm sorry
for asking you so last minute like i understand yeah yeah So
they went in knowing that I, I, I'm fucking made it
possible.
So there would, there are, there would be like, you know,
hiccups around and, uh, and stuff.
So yeah, anyway, one last plug, merch sales end today.
I'm going to go sleep.
Maybe, I don't know.
And I don't fucking know, maybe.
And maybe I'll sleep.
Who knows?
I'm sad that we were buffering the entire time, but it is
what it is.
You know, I already, I will say, like the last, like I said,
anything that could go wrong has went wrong for me, for this
tournament in terms of like organizing it.
And so I, at that point, like, I'm not surprised anymore,
you know?
yeah I was just like at that point I was just I'm not
surprised anymore like that's just you're like oh you
thought it was over you thought it let me just buffer
YouTube today will be down today anyway please check out the
merch guys um please check out the merch and uh support the
merch uh this So yeah, please check it out.
And I hope you guys enjoyed the tournament, everyone.
Like I said, I'm glad some people did enjoy the tournament.
And I'm glad to see Matara having fun time as someone who
doesn't do tournaments and also doesn't play shooters in
general.
So I'm glad she had a fun time.
I'm glad Tara had a fun time too.
And I'm glad people did have a fun time.
you guys.
I'm gonna head off now.
Bye, everybody.
Bye.